ओके। सो वी आर लाइव नाउ। यस हम लाइव आ
चुके हैं काफी दिनों बाद।
ओके। सो लेट एवरीबॉडी जॉइन द सेशन फर्स्ट
एंड देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग। तो पहले
सभी को आ जाने देते हैं।
अह देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग। राइट? तो
यहां मैं चैट को पॉप आउट कर लेता हूं। एंड
सो दैट द चैट इज़ विज़िबल टू अस।
सो
फाइनली वी आर लाइव आफ्टर सो लॉन्ग एंड
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी कि मैं
थोड़ा टाइम ज्यादा ले लिया इस लाइव के आने
के पहले एंड यहां आज जो इस सेशन में धमाका
करेंगे काफी कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला
है। काफी कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग आपके सवालों के
जवाब देने वाला हूं। आई होप आई एम ऑडिबल
एंड विज़िबल। आप मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए।
लाइक इफ आई एम ऑडिबल। प्लीज लेट मी नो कि
मैं अह मेरी जो ऑडियो है वो बिल्कुल आपको
क्लियर जा रही है क्या? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
प्लीज लेट मी नो। एवरीबॉडी।
ओके।
ऑडिबल। बढ़िया। ओके। बढ़िया। सो लाइव चैट
फीचर में एक और नया फीचर आ चुका है। अगर
आप सबको नहीं पता। आपको भी शायद दिख रहा
होगा। आई डोंट नो कि हैश वन करके टू करके
थ्री करके लाइक जो ज्यादा एक्टिव यूज़र्स
हैं हमारे चैट में या लाइव में जो ज्यादा
एक्टिव होते हैं उनके लिए वो जो है वो दी
गई है मार्किंग। राइट? सो इट्स ग्रेट।
इससे ये भी पता चलेगा कि लाइक कौन सबसे
ज्यादा एक्टिव होता है।
एंड
ओके बढ़िया।
हेलो गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी। गुड इवनिंग।
गुड इवनिंग आप सबको। गुड इवनिंग एंड थैंक
यू फॉर जॉइनिंग द लाइव सेशन हियर।
हम
ओके।
सो यहां पे 44 पीपल आर हियर इन द लाइव
सेशन एंड नाउ आई एम पॉपिंग आउट द चैट एंड
देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग टेकिंग
क्वेश्चंस एंड ऑल। तो आज का सेशन एज आई
ऑलरेडी सेड टू ऑल ऑफ यू कि आज का सेशन जो
है वो एक तरीके का इंटरेक्टिव सेशन होने
वाला है बहुत ही ज्यादा जहां पे मैं आपसे
इंटरेक्ट करूंगा। तो वेलकम एवरीवन टू दिस
डाउट सेशन थर्ड डाउट सेशन जो बग बंटी की
हमारी है। एंड ऐसा बहुत रेयर या बहुत कम
देखा जाता है जहां आपको फ्री की एकदम
क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग दी जा रही है एंड वहां
पे आपसे आपके डाउट सेशंस भी लिए जा रहे
हैं। सो दिस इज़ वेरी रेयर एंड भले वो डाउट
सेशंस कम है लेकिन यस आई ब्रिंग इट फॉर यू
ऑल गाइस। तो आपसे आपके प्रॉब्लम्स, आपके
दिक्कतों को सुनने आया हूं मैं। आपके
क्वेरीज को सुनने आया हूं मैं। बग बाउंटी
से रिलेटेड या किसी भी चीज से रिलेटेड कुछ
भी क्वेरी हो यू कैन डायरेक्टली आस्क मी।
यू कैन डायरेक्टली आस्क इन द चैट बॉक्स
आल्सो। एंड कुछ लोगों ने कम्युनिटी पोस्ट
पे भी क्वेश्चंस करे हैं। क्वेरीज उनके
हैं उनके भी आंसर्स जो है मैं करने वाला
हूं। तो सब कुछ देखेंगे करेंगे एंड देन वी
विल बी कंटिन्यूइंग दिस पर्टिकुलर सेशन।
चलिए
तो यहां पे बहुत सारी क्वेरीज आ रही हैं।
बट सबसे पहले हम कम्युनिटी पोस्ट के
क्वेरीज से स्टार्ट करेंगे एंड देन वुड
मूव फॉरवर्ड। राइट? यहां पे
कुछ टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट है। मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं। यहां पे टॉप फैंस पे चलेंगे। तो
ये हमारे कुछ टॉप के फैंस हैं और वन टू 30
रैंकिंग में है। एंड मैं इनको स्पेशल शाउट
आउट देना चाहूंगा। लाइक शिवम गुप्ता हैं,
साइ टॉक हैं, मिस्टर बाइनरी एंटिटी हैं,
स्टम फॉर यू हैं। रुद्र मराठे हैं,
नौसखिया हैं। आयुष पटेल हैं। नवीन सीएस
है, लर्निंग वि काजमी हैं। 10x सिक्योरिटी
मैन 550 जे एमडी राहत योर पैरेट अनूप
प्रजापति अह धुरवी धुरवी ओके बी शो करके
हैं। जेबी भाई जे भाई ओके फारिया क्रेज़
गेमर्स नील नीलू पटेल एिल जेबी अ स्लाइम
प्लेज़
ओके अ केवल सौदीगरा एक्सपी एल टीआर 19
ब्लैक वाइपर नंदीश कुलकर्णी सॉरी अगर नाम
कुछ गलत मैं ले लूं तो उसके लिए भाई
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी क्योंकि यहां पे प्रॉपर
नेम का आ नहीं रहा है अज़ाम टक अनली लीडर
उसके बाद सुर अह सुच सुचैिता दास एंड कोड
हैक। सो दीज़ आर सम टॉप फैंस जो अभी
YouTube ने इंट्रोड्यूस किया है नया लाइव
सेशन में। सो फर्स्ट ऑफ़ आल थैंक यू टू ऑल
दीज़ 30 पीपल एंड
मोर पीपल हु हैव जॉइ द सेशन एंड जो
कंटिन्यू देखते हैं इन 30 लोगों के अलावा
भी जो हैं जो हमारे रेगुलर व्यूअर्स रह
चुके हैं एंड आज भी हैं उनको भी हार्ट
फेल्ट थैंक्स फ्रॉम बॉटम ऑफ माय हार्ट ओके
थैंक यू सो मच फॉर सपोर्टिंग फॉर लविंग
मैं इसलिए बोल रहा हूं क्योंकि एक आपका
सपोर्ट एंड जो आपका जो स्ट्रेंथ है जो
चीजें हैं जो हमारे को मिलती है वो टॉप
टॉप नच की है। एंड उसके बिना आई डोंट थिंक
कि हमें वो इनकरेजमेंट मिलती है या किसी
को भी मिलेगी कि हम आपके लिए चीजें
क्वालिटी लेकर आए। राइट? सो दिस इज वेरी
वेरीेंट। सो फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल गाइस मैं आपसे
एक और चीज कहना चाहूंगा। इस साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी के अंदर हमारे साथ
बहुत लोग जुड़े हुए हैं। इनफैक्ट बहुत
सारे लोग हैं। चाहे वो Telegram पे हो,
चाहे वो Instagram पे हो, चाहे वो
Facebook पे हो, चाहे वो YouTube पे हो,
कहीं पे भी हो। एंड दे ट्रूली सपोर्ट अस।
दे ट्रूली सपोर्ट आवर इनिशिएटिव जो हमारा
इनिशिएटिव होता है जो हमारा अभी करेंटली
इनिशिएटिव है कि आइदर फ्री और मोस्ट
अफोर्डेबल ट्रेनिंग उसको सपोर्ट करते हैं।
एंड अ कई लोग ऐसे होते हैं जो हमारी
ट्रेनिंग्स जो हमारी फ्री कोर्सेज हैं
उसको भी स्प्रेड करते हैं। उसको भी शेयर
करते हैं दूसरों के साथ एंड बताते हैं कि
फ्री की ट्रेनिंग इतनी अच्छी मिल रही है।
तो यू शुड मस्ट बी वाचिंग एंड मस्ट बी
सींग। सो आई एम ग्रेटफुल फॉर दोज़
वॉलंटियर्स आल्सो फॉर दोज़ अनइनवांटेड
वॉलंटियर्स आई वुड से कि जो जिनको हमने तो
नहीं रखा है बट वो खुद ही जो है हमारे लिए
अच्छा सोचते हैं अच्छा करते हैं तो थैंक
यू सो मच चलिए लव यू टू ब्रदर लव यू टू सो
बिफोर वी प्रोसीड विद योर क्वेश्चंस फ्रॉम
चैट वी हैव सम क्वेश्चंस फ्रॉम द
कम्युनिटी पोस्ट जो मैंने आपसे आज पूछा था
एंड यह हमारी कम्युनिटी पोस्ट है अगर आपको
नहीं पता यहां डेफ्रोनिक्स पे पोस्ट पे आप
पाएंगे। एंड इनफैक्ट एक और चीज़ मैं आपको
बताता हूं। पोस्ट पे आप आके ना आप हमारे
कम्युनिटी पोस्ट पे भी कुछ भी पोस्ट कर
सकते हैं। यह नया फीचर है YouTube का। इफ
यू वांट टू ट्राई यू कैन ट्राई इट आउट। आप
हमारे कम्युनिटी पोस्ट पे कुछ भी पोस्ट कर
सकते हैं आप आके। ठीक है? तो यहां पे हमने
क्वेश्चंस पूछे थे। कुछ 15 16 लोगों ने
यहां पे हमसे क्वेश्चंस करे हैं। तो मैं
कुछ जो कॉमन क्वेश्चंस हैं उनको ले लेता
हूं एंड देन हम आगे की तरफ प्रोसीड
करेंगे। हो सकता है इनके क्वेश्चन में
आपके भी कुछ क्वेश्चंस हो या इनके जो आंसर
मिलते हैं उनके उनके आंसर में आपके भी
क्वेरीज जो हैं वो सॉल्व हो जाए। ठीक है?
ओके।
सो फर्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ सर हमें आई ओटी
हैकिंग एंड रैट बनाना सीखना है। ओके? तो
देखो आईओटी सिक्योरिटी इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग
एंड मेकिंग रैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग। नाउ द
पर्पस डिफाइन योर माइंडसेट कि आपका पर्पस
क्या है? उस रैट को क्रिएट करने का। अगर
वो पर्पस इललीगल है,
लीगल नहीं है, सो दैट इज़ नॉट अ दैट शुड
नॉट बी योर पर्पस। एंड अगर आप एक काइंड ऑफ़
ब्लैकहेड चीजें सीखना चाहते हैं, लाइक इफ
यू वांट टू गो एंड सिक्योर थिंग्स बाय
लर्निंग दीज़ ऑल काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स, तो फिर
आप बिल्कुल आप कर सकते हैं। अब रैट के रैट
जो है मॉनिटरिंग पर्पस के लिए भी यूज़ किया
जाता है। डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स। सो इफ
यू आर इफ यू वांटिंग टू क्रिएट एंड डू
समथिंग क्रिएटिविटी क्रिएटिविटी मतलब
क्रिएटिव माइंड के साथ करना चाहते हैं देन
डेफिनेटली यू शुड गो एंड लर्न रही बात आई
ओटी सिक्योरिटी दिस इज़ द फ्यूचर एंड
ऑलरेडी हैपनिंग ये ऑलरेडी चल रही है
फ्यूचर नहीं है ऑलरेडी चल रही है एव्री
अप्लायंसेस जो इलेक्ट्रिकल अप्लायंसेस
होते हैं वो आईओटी डिवाइस में कन्वर्ट
मतलब इंटरनेट ऑफ़ थिंग्स जिसको बोलते हैं
हर एक अप्लायंस जो होता है उसमें एक काइंड
ऑफ़ यू कैन से कि इंटरनेट को कनेक्ट कर
दिया गया है। आपकी एसी हो गई, आपका फ्रिज
हो गया, आपका वाशिंग मशीन हो गया। हर चीज
इंटरनेट से कनेक्ट आज के टाइम में हो रहा
है। एंड वहां पे आईओटी सिक्योरिटी इज़ वेरी
मस्ट। सो यू शुड डेफिनेटली गो एंड पर्स्यू
सम काइंड ऑफ़ नॉलेज अबाउट दीज़ टू टॉपिक्स।
ये अच्छे अच्छे फील्ड्स हैं। नॉलेज आप ले
सकते हैं। अगर आपकोस्ट करनी है, दैट इज़ अ
डिफरेंट थिंग। बट या यू शुड गो।
गिव कंप्लीट ऑफेंसिव एंड डिफेंसिव साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रोड मैप। ओके? ऑफेंसिव एंड
डिफेंसिव साइबर सिक्योरिटी रोड मैप अगर
आपको चाहिए तो हम चैनल पर इसके वीडियो
लेकर आएंगे क्योंकि ऐसे में अगर लाइक इफ
आई आई स्टार्ट टॉकिंग अबाउट दीज़ डू टू
थिंग्स देन इट वुड टेक अ लॉट ऑफ़ लॉट ऑफ़
टाइम बिकॉज़ ये बहुत बड़े टॉपिक्स हैं। बहुत
बड़ी चीज़ है जो आपने पूछा है। दो टर्म्स
हैं बट ये बहुत अपने आप में बहुत बड़े
टर्म्स हैं। सो अह वी वुड ब्रिंग अ लाइक
काइंड ऑफ़ डिटेल वीडियो ओवर दीज़ टू राइट
ऑफेंसिव एंड डिफेंसिव साइबर सिक्योरिटी
रोड मैप थैंक यू एंड अगर वैसे आपको रोड
मैप तब तक के लिए चाहिए कि एक एक मिक्स
रोड मैप चाहिए आपको बहुत ही डिटेल्ड बहुत
ही अच्छा रोड मैप चाहिए तो आप डेफ्रोनिक्स
एकडमी पे ही वीडियो सेक्शन में आ जाइएगा
नीचे की तरफ स्क्रॉल कीजिएगा एंड यहां पे
आपको ना यहां से सबसे लास्ट है मतलब जो
पहली वीडियो आई थी हमारी उससे यहां पे
फिफ्थ वीडियो जो है साइबर सिक्योरिटी
करियर रोड मैप जो कि ऑलमोस्ट आपकी टू
आवर्स की वीडियो है। इसको जरूर देख
लीजिएगा। यह आपके माइंड के जितने भी
क्वेरीज है ना मोस्टली उसको सॉल्व कर
देगा। ओके?
यहां पे एक क्वेश्चन है अंश वर्मा का।
वीएपीटी एंड Android Android पेन टेस्टिंग
कोर्स कब आएगा? Android पे टेस्टिंग की
कोर्स तो अभी रिसेंटली स्टार्ट हुई है। सो
इट वुड टेक अराउंड फोर मंथ्स टू गेट अ
न्यू बैच। बट वीएपीटी की जो बैच है उसकी
अनाउंसमेंट अगस्त महीने में आ रही है। अगर
मैं आपको एक चीज और बता देता हूं। वीएपीटी
का जो बैच है हमारा उसके लिए एक बहुत बड़ी
चीज मैं आपको बताने जा रहा हूं। वीएपीटी
बैच से अभी तक सात फ्रेशर जो स्टूडेंट्स
थे उनकी प्लेसमेंट हुई है कंपनीज़ में।
हमारे बैच से हुई है। जी हां। आपको याद
होगा अगर मैंने वीएपीटी की जब अनाउंसमेंट
करी थी जो हमारा फर्स्ट तब हमने बोला था
कि ये हमारा फर्स्ट ऐसा ट्रेनिंग है जिसको
हम जॉब ओरिएंटेड बोल रहे हैं। हमने आज तक
कभी जॉब ओरिएंटेड टाइप ऐसा कुछ ट्रेनिंग
के अनाउंसमेंट में बोला नहीं था क्योंकि
एक्चुअली वो नहीं होता था। वो इंडस्ट्री
रिलेवेंट जरूर होता था। बट जॉब ओरिएंटेड
हो। जॉब ओरिएंटेड का मतलब ये होना चाहिए
कि आपके उस बैच से ना लोगों की जॉब्स लगनी
चाहिए। लोगों की प्लेसमेंट्स होनी चाहिए।
चाहे जो भी प्लेसमेंट्स होनी जरूर चाहिए।
अगर नहीं हो रही है ना इट मींस कि आप
फर्जी बातें कर रहे हैं एंड योर पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग इज नॉट जॉब ओरिएंटेड। तो मैंने
ऐसे बहुत से इंस्टट्यूट्स एंड कंपनीज़ एंड
ट्रेनिंग प्रोवाइडर्स को देखा है जो लिख
देते हैं 100% जॉब गारंटी 100% प्लेसमेंट
गारंटी और मिलता क्या है? कुछ भी नहीं
मिलता। और उसके उसके दम पे ना आपसे लाखों
रुपए चार्ज किए जाते हैं। यह 10 2000 तो
छोड़ दो। तो 10 2000 तो फिर भी मैं मान
लेता बट लाखों रुपए 70000 80000 1 लाख
1.25 लाख एक्सेस चार्ज किए जाते हैं जॉब
के नाम पे एंड जॉब वहां पे नहीं लगती है।
तो यहां पे हमारे वीएपीटी बैच से जो
डीडीसी एपीटी बैच है डिफ्रॉनिक्स
सर्टिफाइड एडवांस पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर उसमें
सात फ्रेशर स्टूडेंट्स की जॉब लगी है। एंड
कई ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो एकदम बिगिनर्स
थे उनको बाउंटज लगी है। बाउंटज़ जी हां
बाउंटज़ लगी है। तो ये बहुत प्राउड की बात
है हमारे लिए भी। अगर वैसे आप चाहते हैं
नेक्स्ट बैच हमारी बहुत जल्दी आने वाली
है। अगस्त में अनाउंसमेंट आएगी। बट अगर आप
चाहते हैं इसके बारे में और जानना तो आप
इस लिंक पे आ जाइएगा। dfonish.com वीएpटी
पे। यहां पे आके सारी डिटेल्स आप चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे जॉइन द वेटिंग
लिस्ट फॉर नेक्स्ट बैच पे क्लिक करके आप
हमारा WhatsApp ग्रुप है। उसको जॉइ कर
लीजिएगा। वेटिंग लिस्ट का ग्रुप है ये।
जैसे ही आप इसको जॉइ कर लेंगे तो आप जो है
नेक्स्ट बैच के लिए उस वो ग्रुप में ऐड हो
जाएंगे। एंड देन आपको वहीं पे सारी
डिटेल्स वगैरह शेयर कर दी जाएगी। दूसरी
यहां पे क्वेश्चन जो है वो है वेब टू के
बाद वेब थ्री में जाना चाहिए या नहीं?
पैसों के लिए? अरे पैसों के लिए जाना है
तो बिल्कुल जाइए। नोबडी इज स्टॉपिंग बिकॉज़
पैसे के लिए क्यों नहीं जाएंगे आप?
बिल्कुल जाइए। वेब थ्री इज़ आल्सो अ फील्ड
टू एक्सप्लोर एंड वेरी गुड फील्ड। आई वुड
से। तो आपको एक्सप्लोर करना चाहिए। यू शुड
एक्सप्लोर।
यहां पर क्वेश्चन है रुद्र मराठे आई हैव अ
डाउट
आई यूज़ द पेलोड स्क्रिप्ट सर सीन ठीक है
व्हिच इज़ टिपिकली यूज़्ड फॉर ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस टेस्टिंग हाउएवर इट एग्जीक्यूटेड
इमीडिएटली इन द ब्राउज़र आफ्टर सबमिटेड इट
डज़ दिस मीन द वनेबिलिटी इज़ एक्चुअली
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस एंड नॉट ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस और कैन अ ब्लाइंड एक्सेस पे ट्रिगर
इमीडिएटली अंडर हम देखिए
मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं। ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस और एक्सेस के बीच के डिफरेंस को
पहले आपको थोड़ा सा ना कंसेप्चुअली समझना
पड़ेगा। लाइक दिमाग से समझना पड़ेगा। कैसे
समझना पड़ेगा? कोई भी ऐसी पेलोड जो
आपके जैसे यूजर ने पेलोड इनपुट करा एंड वो
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है वहीं पे। जैसे आपके
केस में यहां पे एक पॉपअप के थ्रू
रिफ्लेक्ट हो गई है इंस्टेंटली वहां पे।
वो ब्लाइंड एक्सेसिस का ब्लाइंड एक्सेसिस
नहीं है। दैट इज अ रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस
ओनली। सो यह जो आपका पेलोड है अगर वह
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है तो वो सिर्फ एक
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस है। ब्लाइंड एक्सेस के
केस में जनरली क्या होता है? आपने एक
पेलोड भेजा है और वो पेलोड
बैक एंड में बैक एंड में कहीं पे
एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है। ड्यू टू द एक्शन ऑफ़
दैट पर्टिकुलर यूजर। जैसे बैक एंड में कोई
आपका डेवलपर काम कर रहा है। कोई एक रिस्चर
सिक्योरिटी एक एनालिस्ट काम कर रहा है।
कोई चैट मैनेजर काम कर रहा है। एंड
उन्होंने उस पेलोड से जैसे इंटरेक्ट किया
या उसके सर्विस से जहां पे वो पेलोड इनपुट
इनपुट की गई है उसके बाद अगर वो पॉपअप आता
है तब वो ब्लाइंड एक्सेस कैटेगरी में आता
है। अदरवाइज़ उसके अलावा जस्ट रिफ्लेक्शन
अगर हो रही है इंस्टेंटली जहां पे आपने
पुट किया है वो कभी भी ब्लाइंड एक्सेस
नहीं है। दैट इज़ जस्ट अ रिफ्लेक्टेड
एक्सेस। दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
ओके देयर इज वन मोर क्वेश्चन डिफरेंस
बिटवीन साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन एंड
फॉरेंसिक्स
हां एआई वाली बात पे आते हैं टेंशन मत
लीजिए एआई वाली बात पे आते हैं एआई वाली
चीज पे भी आते हैं बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए
कि एआई का भी बहुत बहुत ज्यादा टेंशन में
है काफी लोग एक्सबो के आने से एक्सबो के
बारे में तो बहुत लोगों को समझ में आ चुका
होगा बहुत लोगों ने न्यूज़ वगैरह देख लिया
होगा अभी हाइप हो गई है पूरी चारों तरफ
एक्सबो एक्सबो करके आ रहा है राइट तो आप
सब ने एक्सबो के बारे में तो मतलब देखा ना
न्यूज़ में एक्सबो के बारे में यू गॉट टू
नो अबाउट एक्सबो एवरीबॉडी प्लीज रेस्पोंड
इन द चैट। मैं चैट दूसरे फोन पे भी देख
रहा हूं। आई हैव अनदर फोन जहां पे चैट
चालू है एंड मैं वहां पे देख रहा हूं आपके
चैट्स। तो आप मुझे बताइए कि एक्सबो जो है
वो उसके बारे में पता चल रहा है सबको? अभी
रिसेंट में आप सबको पता चली होगी। राइट?
हम
ठीक है। तो हम एक्सबो पे भी आएंगे। एक्सबो
मैं इसकी बात कर रहा हूं। सॉरी
आई एम टॉकिंग अबाउट एक्सबो AI मैं इसकी
बात कर रहा हूं जिसके बारे में भी बहुत
ज्यादा हाइप है एंड एक्सो ने जो हैकर वन
की लीडर बोर्ड है उसको टॉप कर लिया है। यह
एक ऐसा एi है जो ऑटोमेशन
एंड बल्क में वनेबिलिटीज ढूंढने के लिए
बहुत पॉपुलर हुआ है। एंड इसको लेके कई ऐसे
बिगिनर्स हैं जिनको ऐसा डर लग रहा है कि
एक्सबो के आ जाने से कहीं बग बंटी की मेरी
जर्नी तो खत्म नहीं हो जाएगी। ऐसा तो नहीं
कि मेरी जो करियर है वो खत्म हो जाएगी। जो
मैं ट्राई कर रहा हूं बनने की या जो मैं
आगे फ्यूचर में बनना चाहता हूं एक अच्छा
बग बंटी हंटर। ऐसा तो नहीं कि मेरे उस पे
इंपैक्ट पड़ेगा। एंड इसको लेके काफी लोग
काफी हवा भी बना रहे हैं। बहुत ज्यादा वो
भी कर रहे हैं। बट इसके बारे में हम बात
करेंगे। एंड इस पे ना आपके लिए एक डिटेल
वीडियो भी मैं लेकर आऊंगा जहां पे एक केस
स्टडी के साथ साथ ही पूरी डिटेल
एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ हर एक चीज हर एक टाइप
के अ पॉसिबिलिटी पे हम बात करेंगे जहां पे
हम एक्सबो को कंपेयर करेंगे ह्यूमन
इंटरेक्शन के साथ कि ह्यूमन इंटरेक्शन एंड
ह्यूमन टच एंड एक्सो दोनों में क्या
डिफरेंस है एक्चुअली एंड व्हाट इट कैन
एक्चुअली इंपैक्ट योर करियर ऑ नॉट बगटी
करियर ठीक है तो हम आएंगे उस पे चलिए
यहां पे एक क्वेश्चन है सर वेब3 ब्लॉकचेन
पे गाइडेंस चाहिए कि कैसे वेब 33 बग बाउंट
स्टार्ट करें कहां से करें ठीक है वेब3 के
ऊपर मैं कोशिश करूंगा एक प्लेलिस्ट बनाने
की आई एम नॉट गिविंग यू गारंटी बट या आई
वुड ट्राई टू ब्रिंग अ प्लेलिस्ट ऑन वेब3
ठीक है ओके एक क्वेश्चन है सर पोर्ट्स
फिगर पे अ
लैब तो सॉल्व कर लेते हैं लेकिन रियल
वेबसाइट में क्या डिफरेंट अप्रोच को फॉलो
करनी चाहिए क्या और बेहतर वे हैं वेब एंड
टेस्टिंग सीखने के हां चलिए एक क्वेश्चन
है। बहुत अच्छा क्वेश्चन है। आप में से कई
लोगों के ये सवाल हो सकते हैं या अगर नहीं
भी है तो आपको ये सवाल करना चाहिए अपने आप
से कि अगर हम लैब के एक लैब एनवायरमेंट के
अंदर एक लैब के अंदर अगर किसी तरह का कोई
प्रोसेस करते हैं पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के
लिए तो क्या रियल वेबसाइट पे हमारी अप्रोच
डिफरेंट होनी चाहिए या कुछ डिफरेंट तरीके
से अलग होना चाहिए या कुछ और होना चाहिए।
सबसे बड़ा एक यहां पे ये सवाल आपसे मैं
पूछना चाहता हूं कि आप जब कहीं पे जाके
किसी तरह की कुछ प्रैक्टिस करते हैं। ठीक
है? अब जैसे मैं आप जाते हो आप मान लो
कराटे सीखने जाते हो। ठीक है? जूडो कराटे
जो भी है कराटे सीखने जाते हो। तो आप
कराटे जब सीखते हो तो आप एक डमी या तो एक
डमी पे सीखते हो या तो आप अपने जो भी
सामने वाला डिफ आपको डिफेंड कर रहा होता
है या बेसिकली आपका जो भी साथ में आपके कर
रहा होता है उसके साथ आप लड़ाई करके या
फाइट करके सीखते हो। राइट? वहां पे जब उस
कराटे को आप मान लो कि एक ऐसी जगह पे जा
रहे हो जहां पे आपको उस कराटे की जरूरत
पड़ जाती है। मान लो रास्ते में कहीं जा
रहे हो। तीन-चार लोगों ने आपको घेर लिया
है एंड वो आप आपके ऊपर हावी हो रहे हैं।
आपको कराटे आती है। बट आपने क्या किया है?
आपने एक बंदे के साथ ही उस कराटे के
स्किल्स को सीखा है। आपको नहीं पता
तीन-चार लोगों को टैकल कैसे करना है।
राइट? बट आपको यह पता है कि मुझे कराटे
में करना क्या होता है। मैं कराटे को किस
तरीके से करूंगा। किस तरीके से उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करूंगा कि सामने वाला जो है वो
हार मान लेगा एंड वो मुझसे हार जाएगा नीचे
गिर जाएगा। राइट? तो सेम चीज आप बाकी
लोगों पे अप्लाई करोगे एंड एग्जीक्यूशन
आपका सेम रहेगा। जो एग्जीक्यूशन है जो
प्रोसेस है वो बिल्कुल सिमिलर रहेगा। कुछ
अलग नहीं रहेगा। क्योंकि जो आपने सीखा है
वही तो आप अप्लाई करोगे ना। जो चीज़ आपने
सीखी ही नहीं है। मान लो उसको अप्लाई कैसे
करोगे? सिमिलर वे अगर आप लैब के साथ कोई
चीज सॉल्व करते हो, लैब्स पे एक्सपेरिमेंट
करते हो, लैब्स पे प्रैक्टिस करते हो तो
आपने वो एक स्किल, एक तरीका सीखा है। अब
उस तरीके को ही आपको लाइव रियल वेबसाइट्स
पे अप्लाई करनी होती हैं। वहां पे हो सकता
है आपका जो मेथोडोलॉजी है या जो आपका आपका
जो तरीका है जो उसको अप्रोच करने का वो
थोड़ा अलग हो सकता है। आई आई कैन अ
आई कैन एक्सेप्ट दिस कि हां ये मैं इस पे
कंफर्म कर सकता हूं कि हो सकता है आपका
तरीका थोड़ा अलग हो बट जो अप्रोच जो थोड़ा
वो अलग हो मान लो लेकिन जो प्रोसेस है ना
जो आपने सीखा है वो सिमिलर रहेगा उस
प्रोसेस में कोई डिफरेंस नहीं आएगी वो
प्रोसेस आपका डिफरेंट नहीं होगा वो
बिल्कुल सिमिलर रहेगा जैसे आपने लैब पे
सॉल्व किया है जैसे आपने लैब पे किया है
वो
सही है सीपीडीएस के करना कितना सही है
सीपीडीएस मैं यहां पे सीपीटीएस
ओके
यहां पे सीपीटीएस आपकी मैं आपको यहां पे
दिखा देता हूं यहां पे ओपन करके
ठीक है जस्ट लेट लेट मी ओपन इट लेट ओके ये
अभी लोड नहीं हो रहा है लेट इट ओपन
ओके इट्स टेकिंग अ बिट टाइम बट
चलो थोड़ा टाइम ले रहा है ये। अ चलिए यहां
पे मैं एक बार और वापस ट्राई करता हूं।
आई एम ट्राइंग अगेन टू ओपन इट। राइट?
मैं आपको एक बार और ओपन करके बताता हूं।
देखो वैसे Infosys राइट अप पे यहां पे एक
रिव्यू यहां पे आपको मिलेगी। एंड इस जब आप
रिव्यू में आप जाएंगे यहां पे तो आप
देखेंगे कि लाइक इसका जो रिव्यू है
मोस्टली जो है इसके बारे में लोग अच्छा ही
बोलते हैं लाइक कि ठीक है बढ़िया है गुड
है तो अभी ये पेज ओपन नहीं हो रहा है बट
मैं आपको फिर वैसे ही बता देता हूं मैं
आपको कुछ दिखा रहा था बट मैं आपको वैसे
बता देता हूं अगर आप
समझते हैं कि आपकी
जो लर्न स्किल है जो आपने सीखी है अभी जो
लर्न किया है जो स्किल आपने सीखा है। उसको
आप एप्लीकेबल मोड में देखना चाहते हैं एंड
चाहते हैं कि आप उसको देखें एग्जीक्यूशन
मोड में कि हां भैया मैंने जो सीखा है वो
एग्जैक्टली कितना सीखा है। एंड क्या
एक्चुअली मैंने कुछ सीखा है? तो आप उससे
अलाइंड जो सर्टिफिकेशंस होती हैं या
एग्जामिनेशंस होती हैं या जो सीटीएस होती
हैं आप उनको अटेम्प्ट कर सकते हैं। अगर
आपको ऐसा लगता है कि मैंने जो सीखा है वो
बेस्ट है। मुझे ऐसी कोई प्रूफ या ऐसी कोई
शो शोबाजी करने के लिए मुझे अपने को प्रूफ
नहीं करना है कि नहीं मैंने जो सीखा है वो
या मुझे अपने आपको मेजर नहीं करना है एक
सर्टिफिकेशन के थ्रू एक सीडीएफ के थ्रू
ऐसा कुछ तो आप उसको छोड़ सकते हैं। यह
पूरा आपका खुद का परसेप्शन है। ये जो
परसेप्शन आपका खुद का है। अगर आप ओएससीपी
लेवल की नॉलेज रखते हैं। मान लो लेट्स
सपोज आप ओएससीपी प्लस लेवल की नॉलेज रखते
हैं। आपको लग रहा है कि चलो उस नॉलेज को
टेस्ट कर लेते हैं कि एक्चुअली मैं जो सोच
रहा हूं जो नॉलेज मेरे अंदर है वो
एक्चुअली में है जो एक्चुअल नॉलेज है
ओएसपी एक बनने के लिए या ओएसपी
क्वालीिफाइड कहलाने के लिए या एक ओएससीपी
कहलाने के लिए तो आप जाइए ओएससीपी के
सर्टिफिकेशन एग्जाम को अटेम्प्ट कीजिए।
अगर आपको लगता है कि नहीं मैंने जो ओएसईपी
सीखा है जो लर्निंग जो नॉलेज जो स्किल ली
है वो मैंने बेस्ट ली है और वो एक्चुअली
मैं अंदर प्रोसेस कर पा रहा हूं एंड मैं
किसी भी ओएसपी कैंडिडेट के साथ बैठ के
उससे नीचे ना हो तो उसके साथ-साथ जरूर चल
सकता हूं या हो सकता है मैं उसको पीछे भी
कर दूं इन टर्म्स ऑफ नॉलेज एंड स्किल। तो
अगर आपको ऐसा लगता है तो फिर आपको कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है किसी भी सर्टिफिकेशन
किसी भी तरह के इस तरह के पेपर की। ठीक
है? मैं इतना ही जानता हूं। तो दोनों में
से आप खुद से डिसाइड करना होता है या आप
किसी से भी मत पूछिए कि मेरे को यह
सर्टिफिकेशन करना चाहिए कि नहीं। मुझे वो
करना चाहिए कि नहीं। डोंट आस्क एनीबॉडी।
दैट्स इट। सबका अपना-अपना परसेप्शन रहेगा।
सबका अपना-अपना व्यू रहेगा। वो आपको
बताएंगे भी। तो क्या पता उनका एक बायस
व्यू है उस पर्टिकुलर सब सर्टिफिकेशन के
लिए एंड आप कुछ और मांग रहे हो आप अनबायस
व्यू व्यू मांग रहे हो तो आप खुद से पूछो
ना कि मुझे अगर उतनी आती है जितनी मैं सोच
रहा हूं एंड मैं चाहता हूं टेस्ट करना गो
फॉर द सर्टिफिकेशन एंड इफ यू आर योर बजट
फ्रेंडली मतलब ठीक है बजट है आपको लगता है
कि नहीं यार इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है
मुझे इतना पता है कि अगर मैं किसी ओएसपी
कैंडिडेट के साथ भी डिबेट करूं तो मैं
उसको ना उस डिबेट में हरा सकता हूं तो यू
डोंट नीड द सर्टिफिक िफिकेशन आई थिंक यू
ऑल अंडरस्टुड दिस। आप सबको यह चीज मेरी
बात समझ में आई? मैं क्या बोलना चाह रहा
था अभी इस पर्टिकुलर चीज के थ्रू? इस आपके
सवाल के आंसर के थ्रू मैंने आपको क्या
समझाना चाहा वो आपको समझ में आया क्या?
मैं आपको कुछ अलग लेवल की चीज समझाने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं। आपको अभी जो मैंने
बताया वो मैंने कुछ और समझाने की कोशिश की
है ताकि आपको ना एक्चुअल समझ में आए। आपको
किसी पर डिपेंड होने की जरूरत ना पड़े कि
यू जस्ट गो एंड आस्क एवरीबडी व्हाट टू
व्हिच सर्टिफिकेशन टू डू व्हाई टू डू कैसे
करना है क्यों करना है भैया ये मैं समझा
रहा था राइट गॉट इट अब यहां पे एक
क्वेश्चन है यहां पे कि एक ईडब्ल्यूपीटी
एंड ये इसी इनका जो एक सर्टिफिकेशन आता है
जो बिगिनर सर्टिफिकेशन इन दोनों में कौन
अच्छा है ऑलवेज गो फॉर ईडब्ल्यूपीटी ऑलवेज
गो फॉर ईडब्ल्यूपीटी आप ईलन सिक्योरिटी के
यानी कि यू कैन ईलन सिक्योरिटी या फिर अब
तो आईएई है वो तो आईएई के सर्टिफिकेशंस को
आप ज्यादा प्रेफरेंस दे सकते हैं हमेशा
एंड देना भी चाहिए आपको रेदर देन अ जो
आपके पहले के कुछ मास्टर लोग हैं इस
पर्टिकुलर सर्टिफिकेशन फील्ड में। ठीक है?
ओके। आई होप एवरीबडी गॉट द आंसर कि कौन से
सर्ट सीपीटीएस करना चाहिए या नहीं या फिर
कोई भी सर्टिफिकेशन के लिए मैंने बात की
है। ठीक है? चलिए एक क्वेश्चन है। सर मैं
अब बीटेक फाइनल ईयर स्टूडेंट हूं। मैं
इससे पहले बग बाउंट सीख रहा था। क्या मुझे
अब भी वह सीखना सीखते रहना चाहिए या जॉब
के लिए प्रिपरेशन करनी चाहिए? सबसे पहली
बात ज्ञानश यू आर आई आई एम ज्ञानेश। अगर
आप बीटेक थर्ड ईयर या फाइनल ईयर में हैं
एंड अगर आप पहले से बग बाउंटज करते हैं तो
आपको अभी बग बाउंटज में एक अच्छा पोजीशन
अचीव कर लेना होना चाहिए। कर लिया होना
चाहिए। मेरे ख्याल से आपको अच्छा खासा
एक्सपीरियंस हो गया होगा। आई वुड सजेस्ट
यू टू शिफ्ट योर अ लाइक लर्निंग एंड ऑल
थिंग। वीएपीटी में शिफ्ट कीजिए थोड़ा सा।
बग बंटी जस्ट बग बंटी में ही लिमिटेड मत
रहिए। मैं कभी भी किसी को भी यह नहीं
बोलता कि जस्ट गेट लिमिटेड टू बग बंटीज।
अगर बग बंटीज में आप इतने अच्छे हो गए
हैं, इतने एक्सपर्ट हो गए हैं कि आपको
किसी और चीज की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है, तब
तो आप ठीक है। बहुत बढ़िया है। यू शुड
कंटिन्यू बग बंटीज जर्नी एंड दिन रात करते
रहिए। दिन रात करते रहिए। एंड डेफिनेटली
यू विल गेट सक्सेस एंड इट यू विल गेट
ह्यूज सक्सेस वन डे। बट अगर आपको लगता है
कि नहीं थोड़ा बहुत डामाडोल टाइप है थोड़ा
इधर-उधर भी मैं हो सकता हूं तो आप वीएपीटी
की तरफ शिफ्ट हो सकते हैं अपने आपको। एंड
उसी के साथ आपकी जॉब की प्रिपरेशन ऑलरेडी
हो रही है। क्योंकि वीएपीटी डोमेन में
काफी सारे जॉब्स हैं। काफी कंपनीज़ रेगुलर
बेसिस पे हायर करती हैं। एंड अगर आपके
अंदर वो स्किल है तो नोबडी कैन डिफेंड
नोबडी कैन लाइक डिफिट यू बेसिकली। ठीक है?
ओके।
ओके द नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ अगेन सर
सर्टिफिकेट इज गुड फॉर बिगिनर्स वही
सर्टिफिकेट जो काफी अ बिगिनर फ्रेंडली
सर्टिफिकेट है एंड आफ्टर दिस सर्टिफिकेट
कहां जाना चाहिए लाइक फॉर अनदर सर्टिफिकेट
और सर्च फॉर अ जॉब और व्हिच फील्ड देखिए
इससे बढ़िया है आप आईएई के एक बेसिक
सर्टिफिकेशन कर लीजिए लाइक ईजेपीटी इस
टाइप के सर्टिफिकेशन कर लीजिए एंड दूसरा
जो है आप यू कैन गो एंड अ यू कैन गो एंड
गो फॉर ओएसईबी। डायरेक्ट आप ओएसईबी के लिए
जाइए। उसके बाद मैं यही बोलूंगा अगर आपका
बजट टाइट नहीं है तो आप जाइए। जब बजट टाइट
है तो थोड़ा वेट कीजिए एंड देन आप जाइए।
ओके
हम
ओके। सो देयर इज़ अनदर क्वेश्चन। आई वांट
टू डू वेब पेंट्रेशन टेस्टिंग व्हेन विल
योर वेब पेन टेस्टिंग बी लॉन्च्ड? इसमें
मैंने खुद ने टेक्निकल नेविगेटर वाले से
रिप्लाई भी किया है कि अगर आपको सिर्फ वेब
पे टेस्टिंग सीखनी है ना भैया तो कहां
जाना है? क्यों जाना है यार? मतलब मैं समझ
नहीं रहा। आप वेब पे टेस्टिंग आपको सीखनी
है तो कोर्स क्यों करनी है? पेड कोर्स
क्यों करनी है? आप लाइव में आइए यहां पे।
लाइव नहीं प्लेलिस्ट में ही आ जाओ यार।
चलो प्लेलिस्ट में आ जाओ।
हम
एंड यहां पे बग बंटी की फ्री ट्रेनिंग की
प्लेलिस्ट है। ठीक है?
इसको
पूरी प्लेलिस्ट होल प्लेलिस्ट यू हैव टू
वाच वीडियो नंबर वन डे वन से लेकर अभी तक
यहां पे 55 जो वीडियोस आई हैं उन सबको आप
देख जाइए एंड दैट्स इट इतना ही आपको चाहिए
इसके इससे ज्यादा आपको नहीं चाहिए बस
दैट्स इट इतना ही करना है एंड आप बहुत कुछ
वेब एप्लीकेशन पे टेस्टिंग से सीख जाएंगे
हमने इस सीरीज में पूरी वेब टॉप 10
ऑलमोस्ट कवर कर दी है एंड वेब सिक्योरिटी
पोर्ट सिक्योरिटी की लाइक वेब सिक्योरिटी
एकडमी पोच फिगर वाली उसकी कई सारी टॉपिक्स
को कवर किया है। अगर कोई बहुत समझदार बंदा
होगा या बहुत ज्यादा
दिमाग वाला बंदा होगा वो सिर्फ इस
प्लेलिस्ट से बहुत कुछ अचीव कर सकता है।
बिलीव मी काफी लोगों ने किया है। आप भी कर
सकते हैं। बस एक ट्राई कीजिए। स्टार्ट
कीजिए बिना सोचे समझे। जस्ट स्टार्ट।
सोचना नहीं है कि कब से करना है, क्या
करना है। अरे 50 55 वीडियोस हैं। कब अरे
यार कैसे होगा। डे वन से स्टार्ट करो।
प्रैक्टिस शुरू करो। एक वीडियो पे एक दिन
में टाइम दो। तो एक दिन में एक वीडियो
टाइम पूरा करके वो करो एंड दैट्स इट डन
ओके
ओके हेलो डीजे अभी हाउ आर यू ब्रदर चलिए
तो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं यहां पे एंड हम
यहां पे ऊपर से क्वेश्चंस लेना शुरू करते
हैं क्योंकि मैं ऊपर इसलिए स्क्रॉल कर रहा
हूं क्योंकि मैं नीचे से क्वेश्चन ले लूं
ऊपर के ना लूं तो ये जस्टिफाइड नहीं होगा।
राइट? तो चलिए
सर व्हाट शुड आई कवर फर्स्ट डीईएई और बग
बंटी कोर्स? सबसे पहले आप बग बंटी को शुरू
कीजिए एंड जब बग बंटी के कुछ वीडियोस 10
क्लासेस हो जाए तो पैरेलली डीएचई को
स्टार्ट कर दीजिए डे वन से। ठीक है? बग
बंटी इज़ लॉन्ग टर्म करियर नॉट। लॉन्ग टर्म
करियर आज भी पहले भी था, आज भी है और आगे
भी रहेगा। अपने आप को अपने आप को ना
जीनियस की तरह देखिए। मैं आपको यही
बोलूंगा कि लुक योरसेल्फ एज अ जीनियस। अगर
आपने खुद को जीनियस की तरह नहीं देखा तो
फिर आप ना लिमिटेड नॉलेज के साथ रह
जाएंगे। एक पर्टिकुलर डोमेन में जब आप
जीनियस बन जाएंगे ना तो उस डोमेन में आपको
हराने वाला कोई जल्दी मिलेगा नहीं और जो
मिलेंगे वो आपके दोस्त बन जाएंगे। बस इतना
ही मुझे पता है। ठीक है? अगर मैं यहां पे
बात करूं सेम मैं आपको आयरन मैन का
एग्जांपल दे देता हूं। आप सबको शायद आयरन
मैन के बारे में पता होगा। या यू माइट बी
नोइंग अ अगर आप मार्वेल फैन हैं या आयरन
मैन आपने देखी है तो तो व्हाट रॉबर्ट
डाउनी जूनियर वाज़ लाइक ही वाज़ आल्सो अ
जीनियस राइट तो उसने अपने जीनियस माइंड से
सब कुछ प्रिपेयर किया खड़ा वो अलग बात है
दैट इज़ जस्ट अ मूवी एंड कॉमिक्स बट स्टिल
अगर हम रियल लाइफ को भी उससे मैच करके
देखें कनेक्ट करके देखें तो वी ऑल शुड बी
थिंकिंग ऑफ बिकमिंग अ जीनियस। जब जीनियस
बन जाएंगे ना तो आपको यह सोचने की जरूरत
ही नहीं है कि लॉन्ग टर्म करियर है या
शॉर्ट टर्म करियर है। इसका एक्चुअल कोई
करियर है या नहीं है। जिस फील्ड में आप
जीनियस होंगे उस फील्ड में आपका करियर भी
है और आपकी पूछ भी होगी। लोग आपको खोजेंगे
एंड आपको कहीं जाने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी।
लोग आपके पीछे-पीछे आ जाएंगे। राइट?
चलिए
वी फाउंड प्राइस मैनपुलेशन, वनेबिलिटी एंड
टैग्ड यू ऑन Lindin और अनफॉर्चूनेटली इट
वाज़ डुप्लीकेट। कोई बात नहीं
कांग्रेचुलेशंस आप लोग काफी अच्छा कर रहे
हैं रुद्र एंड आरओ अह आप लोगों की काफी
सारी वनेरेबिलिटीज़ रिपोर्ट होती है एंड आप
लोग टैग करते हो मुझे पता भी चलता है सो
गुड वर्क कंटिन्यू ओके
ओके यहां पे क्वेश्चन है अगेन जो मैं
एक्सपेक्ट कर रहा था सर एक्सबो हैकिंग एi
टूल्स के बारे में बताओ देखो ये क्वेश्चन
है एक्सबो हैकिंग टूल्स के बारे में एi
टूल्स के बारे में आपको बताओ तो मैं आपको
इसके बारे में थोड़ा सा
अच्छा आप लोगों को कोई दिक्कत तो नहीं है?
बीच में मैं कुछ खा रहा हूं तो
मैं वो
मंचिंग कर रहा हूं थोड़ा
कुछ कुछ ऐसे छोटे-छोटे ये छोटे-छोटे
टेबलेट्स खा रहा हूं मैं। ये टेबलेट नहीं
है यार। ये नमकीन टाइप है ये।
हम हम
हेल्थ इज
हमें भी खिला दीजिए सर आ जाइए सर आप आ
जाइए
हम हम
आ जाओ भाई आ जाओ मना किसने किया है आओगे
तो बिल्कुल खाओगे चलिए ओके ओके
नहीं डीसीएपीटी के मेंटर कोई और है जो कि
फोर प्लस इयर्स ऑफ एक्सपीरियंस होल्ड करते
हैं इन वीएपीडी डोमेन एंड सीनियर
सिक्योरिटी कंसलटेंट है एंड एन एमएसी
मल्टीीनेशनल कंपनी एंड ही इज द बेस्ट ओके
सर एक्सबो हैकिंग एआई टूल्स के बारे में
बताओ हां तो अब एक्सबो पे आ जाते हैं
थोड़ा सा ठीक है काफी लोगों के दिमाग में
ये चीज आ चुकी है। काफी लोगों के सवाल आ
रहे हैं। रिसेंटली मेरे एक एक फॉलोअर, एक
स्टूडेंट, एक लर्नर के तरफ से मैसेज आया
कि सर क्या मुझे मेरी बग बंटी या मेरी जो
जर्नी है अभी बग बंटी वाली उसको छोड़ देना
चाहिए। मुझे कुछ और करना चाहिए। मैंने
पूछा क्यों? क्या हुआ?
सर एक्सबो आ चुका है एंड मुझे अब डर लग
रहा है। मुझे मुझे घबराहट हो रही है कि
मैंने इतने टाइम से इतना कुछ किया तो यह
सारा वेस्ट शायद हो गया क्योंकि अब एक्सबो
आ गया है तो अब व्हाई पीपल विल
डू मैनुअल थिंग्स एंड ऑल। राइट? ये एक
सवाल था। एंड ये वैलिड क्वेश्चन था। आप
लोगों में से कई लोगों के पास ये
क्वेश्चंस हो सकते हैं। अब एक्सबो को एज अ
टूल यूज़ डेवलप किया गया है। बुक का डेमो
पे आप आएंगे यहां पे। सॉरी।
तो यहां पर आपको ईमेल आईडी नेम, कंपनी नेम
डाल के साइन अप करना होता है। एंड आप उसके
बाद बुक डेमो बुक कर सकते हैं। यहां पे आ
रहा है बूस्टिंग ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी विद
ए। ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी एआई से बूस्ट हो
रही है। अच्छी बात है। एक्सबो ऑटोनॉमसली
फाइंड्स एंड एक्सप्लइट्स वनेबिलिटीज़ इन
75% ऑफ़ वेब बेंचमार्क्स। पहली बात यहां पे
75% लिखा गया है। ठीक है? इट मींस इट इट्स
नॉट नीडेड कि 75% होगा। मान लो 70% है।
30% कहां है? 30% तो अभी भी गायब है। पहली
बात फर्स्ट थिंग राइट? जहां हम 90 प्लस की
बात ना करें वहां कुछ भी अस्यूम करना इज़
नॉट गुड। तो यहां पे 70% अगर है तो 30%
कहां है? उसके बारे में भी हम बात करेंगे
सबसे पहले। ठीक है?
अब
इन्होंने 75% पोर्चुगल लैब सॉल्व किया अभी
तक। ठीक है? यहां भी 90 प्लस नहीं है। 72%
यहां पेंटेस्टर एंड 85% नोवेल बेंचमार्क
यहां पे इन्होंने सॉल्व किया। ठीक है?
चलिए
अब देखिए यहां पे मैं आपको इन्हीं के
वेबसाइट पे इनका ही स्टेटमेंट पढ़ाता हूं।
देन आप डिसाइड कीजिएगा। एक्सबो पर्सूस हाई
लेवल गोल्स बाय एग्जीक्यूटिंग कमांड्स एंड
रिव्यूइंग देयर आउटपुट विदाउट एनी ह्यूमन
इंटरवेंशन। ठीक है?
गॉट इट? समझ में आ गया?
अब देखिए
यहां पर मैं नीचे आता हूं। नीचे आता हूं।
यहां पे कुछ इन्होंने केसेस दिए हैं। सम
केसेस आर हियर बेकिंग अ क्रिप्टोग्राफिक
कैप्चर विथ अ सीबीसी पैडिंग ओरेकल। उसके
बाद कुछ और केसेस पे आएंगे। तो यहां पे
आईडीओआर का यहां पे इन्होंने दिया है
ग्राफ केल एपीआई में। देन यहां पे डीबगिंग
टेस्टिंग एंड रिफाइनिंग अ जेनकिंस रिमोट
कोड एग्जीक्यूशन एक्सप्लइट को इन्होंने
एग्जांपल के तौर पे दिया है। रिसर्चिंग
एबिलिटी एक्सप्लइट फॉर नोट जेएस वनेबिलिटी
के उसके बारे में यहां पे इन्होंने बताया
हुआ है। तो इन्होंने जितने भी ये केसेस
मेंशन कर रखे हैं। ठीक है? यहां पे जो भी
केसेस मेंशन कर रखे हैं, यह ऐसी
वनेबिलिटीज
के लिए टूल बनाई गई है। यह जो टूल है, यह
बेसिकली बल्क फाइंडिंग के लिए बनाई गई है।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है जब बल्क फाइंडिंग के
लिए ऐसे टूल्स एआई का यूज करके बनाए गए
हैं। तो जो लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स हैं, जो
बेसिक लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स होते हैं, जो लो
हैंगिंग वनेबिलिटीज हैं, उनको थोड़ा
ढूंढना अब मुश्किल हो जाएगा। यह तो फैक्ट
है। दिस इज़ फैक्ट बाय जैसे पहले भी क्या
होता था? देखो मैं आपको एक चीज़ बताता हूं।
एक्सबो आया इसकी वजह से नहीं है। एक्सबो
से पहले भी कई ऐसे हैकर्स थे जो बग बंटी
हंटर्स थे जो अपना ऑटोमेशन यूज़ करते थे।
जिन्होंने खुद का एक पूरा ऑटोमेशन बना के
रखा हुआ था और उसी ऑटोमेशन का यूज़ करते थे
लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स को फाइंड करने में।
सिमिलर वे एक्सबो इज़ आल्सो डूइंग द सेम
थिंग। बट क्योंकि इसके पास एक अच्छी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन, एक अच्छी टेक्नोलॉजी है, एक
अच्छी चीज, एक बहुत हाई एंड टेक्नोलॉजी
यूज़ हो रही है। एंड यहां पे एआई को
इंटीग्रेट किया गया है। रिसोर्सेज ज्यादा
यूज़ हो रहे हैं। तो यहां ये बल्क में उन
काम को करेगा। जैसे एक कोई हैकर है उसने
ऑटोमेशन किया तो अपने लिए खुद का ऑटोमेशन
करके खुद का एक टारगेट पे ऑटोमेट करके एंड
उसको एग्जीक्यूट करता है। एक्सबो यहां पे
एक पूरी की पूरी बल्क
में एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए बनाया है।
जैसे कि मान लो कि ये एक्सबो कॉप चला दिया
आपने। अब यह क्या करेगा? बहुत सारे
टारगेट्स पे लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स ढूंढना
शुरू कर देगा एंड आपको जो है ढूंढ-ढूंढ के
लाके दे देगा। राइट? यह पहले रिसर्चरर्स
भी करते थे। बग बंटी हंटर्स भी करते थे
ऑटोमेशन के थ्रू। राइट? अब वो बहुत ज्यादा
टारगेट्स पे शायद उतना ना कर पाए
एफिशिएंटली जितना एक्सबो आपका कर देगा। तो
ज्यादा डिफरेंस नहीं है। बट यहां पे ये
क्योंकि अब एआई को यूज़ में लिया गया है।
सो अ रीडिंग सो अंडरस्टैंडिंग द पैटर्न्स
रीजनिंग समहाऊ एंड ये सब चीजें थोड़ा यहां
पे आ जाता है। बट अगर हम बात करें बिज़नेस
लॉजिक वलेबिलिटीज़ की व्हेनएवर वी आर
टॉकिंग अबाउट बिज़नेस लॉजिक वलेबिलिटी देन
वहां पे एक्सपो जैसी जो टूल्स हैं वो काम
नहीं करेंगी। वहां पे ह्यूमन ही है जिनकी
रिक्वायरमेंट होने वाली है। ऐसी वनेबिलिटी
जिसमें कॉम्प्लेक्स
रीजनिंग की रिक्वायरमेंट है। कॉम्प्लेक्स
सिचुएशन है। ऐसी सिचुएशन जहां पे एक अलग
माइंडसेट रख के उसको एग्जीक्यूट करने की
जरूरत पड़ रही है। एंड कुछ इनोवेटिव
एग्जीक्यूशन चाहिए। उस केस में एक्सबो काम
नहीं आएगा। उस केस में ह्यूमन ही काम
आएंगे। ह्यूमन ब्रेन ही काम आएगा। क्योंकि
ह्यूमन ब्रेन ही ओनली ऐसा
ऐसी चीज है जो
मिक्स्ड काइंड ऑफ रीजनिंग को एग्जीक्यूट
करने में कैपेबल है। जो टफ सिचुएशन में एक
कॉम्प्लेक्स रीजनिंग को सॉल्व करने के लिए
कैपेबल है। यह एक्सबो नहीं कर पाएगी
क्योंकि एक्सबो जो है वो कुछ नहीं एक अनदर
एआई टूल है। जैसे बाकी जो एआई टूल्स है
उसी तरीके का एक एआई टूल है जिसको बग
बाउंट या बेसिकली पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग में
यूज किया जाने वाला है। तो इसको लेके जो
हवा बनाया जा रहा है बहुत सारे लोग बना
रहे हैं कि अरे जर्नी करियर खत्म हो
जाएगी। कुछ नहीं रखा बग बाउंट में। अब
क्या ही होगा वो 100% सही नहीं है। गलत है
वो।
आपको एआई को सीखना चाहिए।
नॉट इस नॉट इन फियर ऑफ दैट कि आपको यह
रिप्लेस कर देगा या आपकी जॉब को खतरे में
डाल देगा। आपको इनके साथ अलाइन होना
चाहिए। यू शुड बी लर्निंग अबाउट एक्सबो बट
एट द सिमिलर टाइम एट द सेम टाइम यू शुड बी
एनहांसिंग योर स्किल्स
एंड टू गेट रेडी टू यूज़ दिस एक्सबो एंड टू
लेट दिस पर्टिकुलर टूल टू वर्क ऑन योर
बिहाफ। आपके बिहाफ में यह काम करे। ये चीज
आपको उस कैपेबिलिटी पे आना पड़ेगा। ये आप
समझ रहे हैं आप सबके?
यह उस कैपेबिलिटी पे आपको लेकर आना
पड़ेगा। दैट्स इट। और कुछ नहीं। तो अगर
आपको यह लग रहा है कि एक्सबो के आ जाने से
अरे भैया एक्सबो देखो मैं आपको बताता हूं।
सिंपल सा बात है। एआई चार्जपीटी जैसी चीज
आई। लाइक चार्जपीटी जैसी चीजें आ गई।
चार्जपीटी के अलावा जेमिनाई जैसी चीजें आ
गई। ठीक है? और पर फ्लेक्सिटी एक्स ए जो
ग्रॉक आया और पता नहीं क्या-क्या चीजें आ
गई तो क्या अभी क्या न्यूज़ में आता था
अरे अब तो एआई आ गई अब सबकी जॉब चली जाएगी
भैया अब तो ना तो सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर्स की
जरूरत पड़ेगी ना तो टेस्टर की जरूरत यही
आया था ना मैं ऐसे हजारों लोगों को जानता
हूं जो डेवलपर्स हैं टेस्टर्स हैं
एनालिस्ट्स हैं सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट हैं
कंसलटेंट हैं जो आज भी जॉब कर रहे हैं
नौकरी कर रहे हैं उनकी जॉब तो नहीं गई
वो तो नौकरी उनकी खत्म नहीं हुई। दे आर
वॉकिंग। तो क्योंकि उन्होंने अपने आप को
भी अपग्रेड किया है। अपने आप को अपस्किल
किया है। उन्होंने भी एआई की नॉलेज ले ली
है। और एआई आया है ना कि आपको रिप्लेस
करने के लिए बट आप उसके नॉलेज को लेके
उससे सीख के और उससे ही काम कराएं। आपको
ऐसा बनना है। यू हैव टू बिकम लाइक दैट
पर्सन। कि यू हैव टू गैब द नॉलेज स्किल।
एंड यू हैव टू लेट इट वर्क फॉर यू। यू शुड
नॉट बी वर्किंग फॉर एआई। एआई शुड बी
वर्किंग फॉर यू। सो यू शुड गेन द स्किल
फर्स्ट दैट विल गिव दैट लेवरेज द पावर।
एंड देन आप उसके पावर को लेवरेज कीजिए।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है इट्स पावरफुल। बट यू
शुड बी लेवरेजिंग। यू शुड बी नोइंग हाउ टू
वरेज दैट पावर
फॉर योर ओन वर्क। एंड देन आपको देखिए कौन
हटा देता है। देन आपकी करियर कौन खराब कर
देता है। देखिए कोई नहीं कर पाएगा। ना कोई
आपको हटा पाएगा। आज ले ले ऑफ्स होते हैं।
Amazon में, Microsoft में, Google में
लेऑ्स होते हैं। कई लोगों को जॉब से
निकाला जाता है। पता है किनको निकाला जाता
है? क्यों निकाला जाता है? आपको समझ में
आता है। आपको पता है क्यों निकाला जाता
है? क्योंकि कुछ ऐसे एंप्लाइज होते हैं जो
यह मानने को ही तैयार नहीं है कि हमारी एक
जो एरा है वह अपग्रेड हो चुकी है। नाउ दिस
एरा इज़ बीन एरा ऑफ़ आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस
इज़ बीन एरा ऑफ़ आईओटी इज़ बीन एरा ऑफ़ मशीन
लर्निंग इज़ बीन एरा ऑफ़ रोबोट्स इज़ बीन एरा
ऑफ़ लाइक अ एवरीथिंग दैट इज़ कनेक्टेड टू
एआई।
ड्रोंस का एरा है। तो जब ऐसी एरा आ चुकी
है तो यू शुड बी अपग्रेडिंग टू दिस एरा
रेदर देन क्राइंग इन द कॉर्नर कि भैया आप
तो मैं तो ये आर एआई आ गया अब तो मैं कुछ
नहीं कर सकता। मैं क्या करूं? मेरा तो
करियर बर्बाद हो गया है। मैं तो अब कुछ
आगे बढ़ ही नहीं सकता। मेरे को ले ऑफ कर
देंगे। मैं आगे जाऊंगा। कंपनी वाले मुझे
निकाल देंगे। भैया क्यों निकालेंगे? हां
निकालेंगे ना। आप मेरे घर पे आओगे। अब
मेरे घर में एक रूल है कि आपको शूज बाहर
निकाल कर आने हैं। अब आप शूज पहन के आ गए।
नहीं नहीं मैं तो नहीं निकालूंगा। मेरे को
तो शूज नहीं निकालना। मेरी मेरी इज्जत चली
जाएगी मेरी यार। मेरे को शूज कैसे निकलवा
दिया? आप अंदर आ गए। अब अंदर से तो मार के
भगाए ही तो जाओगे। है ना? अंदर से आपको तो
भगाया ही जाएगा ना कि व्हाई यू डिड नॉट
फॉलो द रूल्स? सो व्हाई यू डिड नॉट फॉलो द
ट्रेंड? द क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाई यू आर नॉट
फॉलोइंग द ट्रेंड। सो इट्स द ट्रेंड टू
लर्न एआई एंड इंप्लीमेंट एआई इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। उस इंप्लीमेंटेशन को करना
सीखिए और उसको गैब करना सीखिए। उससे काम
कराना सीखिए ना कि भागना सीखिए ना तो रोना
सीखिए। कुछ नहीं होगा उससे।
दैट्स इट। आप सबको समझ में आ रहा है क्या
मैं बोलना चाह रहा हूं? आर यू गेटिंग माय
पॉइंट? एवरीबॉडी? मुझे बताइए एक बार।
बताइए मुझे चैट में।
हम
लेट मी नो। इफ यू आर गेटिंग प्लीज लेट मी
नो।
सबको नहीं समझ में आया लगता है। सभी लोग
बताइए।
बढ़िया। सर आपका 10 एपिसोड देख रहा हूं।
टिप दो। मेरा कौन सा 10 एपिसोड है? बग
बंटी का होगा।
थैंक्स फॉर योर मोटिवेशन सर। वेलकम रुद्र।
एपीआई पेंटेस्टिंग में स्कोप है अभी।
बिल्कुल है यार। बिल्कुल है। सब जगह स्कोप
है। मत सोचो कि स्कोप नहीं है। कभी मत
सोचो।
विनय
कंपनी के लिए है इंडिविजुअल के लिए भी आ
जाएगी क्या फर्क पड़ता है राइट क्या फर्क
पड़ता है किसी के लिए भी आ जाए आगे चलके
इंडिविजुअल के लिए भी ये ल्च कर देंगे तो
उससे क्या फर्क पड़ता है
सर मैं लास्ट ईयर में हूं आपका लाइव साइबर
क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन डीसीसीआई जॉइ कर
सकता हूं क्या डीसीसीआई ट्रेनिंग विकास
क्लास का क्वेश्चन है सर मैं लास्ट ईयर
में हूं। क्या मैं आपका साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन डीसीसीआई जॉइ कर सकता हूं
क्या? बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल आप
कर सकते हैं। बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं। जिनको
नहीं पता डीसीसीआई ट्रेनिंग में क्या क्या
ये क्वेश्चन पूछ रहे हैं। तो बेसिकली
हमारा एक लाइक साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
का ट्रेनिंग होता है। उसकी न्यू बैच आ रही
है 30 जुलाई से 30 जुलाई। उसमें आप एनरोल
कर सकते हैं। अभी भी एनरोलमेंट चालू है
एंड इन अ ऑफर फी तो आपको dfonic.com dcc
इस पे आ जाना है। सिंपल सा जो लोग भी
इंटरेस्टेड हैं साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में लॉ इनफोर्समेंट एजेंसीज
के साथ काम करने में क्राइम्स साइबर
क्राइम्स को सॉल्व करने में या नॉलेज के
लिए चाहते हैं या स्किल गेन करना चाहते
हैं उसके लिए भी। तो आप इस पे आ जाइएगा।
यहां पे सिलेबस डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा।
सिलेबस देख लीजिएगा। इसमें बहुत डिटेल
बहुत कुछ सिलेबस में बहुत इन डेप्थ सिलेबस
है ये जहां पे आपको इसकी पूरी सिलेबस दिख
जाएगी इसमें कि हम क्या-क्या इस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग में आपको कराने वाले हैं वो पूरा
सिलेबस है एक बार देख के एंड देन जो है आप
माइंडसेट बना लीजिएगा एंड आके आप यहां पे
कहीं पे भी एनरोल कर लीजिएगा सिंपल
एनरोलमेंट के टाइम आपको टोटल फी जो है
12,000 थी हमारी बट अभी हमने 9000 ही इसको
रखा है एंड यहां 9000 रखा है फर्स्ट 30
स्टूडेंट के लिए और 30 स्टूडेंट फुल हो
चुके हैं तो एक एक्सटेंड किया हमने सीट्स
तो यू जस्ट हैव टू पे फोर 4500 एट द
एनरोलमेंट एंड रिमेनिंग 4000 जो है वो
सॉरी रिमेनिंग 4500 जो है आपको आफ्टर वन
मंथ 30 अगस्त तक आपको करना होता है। इवन
वन टाइम करते हो तो नाइन के जगह 8500 ही
देने आपको पड़ेंगे। दैट्स इट। तो इस पे
आके आप इसको डिटेल्स चेक आउट कर लीजिएगा।
टोटल 50 सीट्स में से 30 सीट्स तो ऑलरेडी
फुल हो चुके हैं। अ रिमेनिंग जो है वो फुल
होते एनरोलमेंट क्लोज कर दी जाएगी। सो
इसका एक सवाल था। तो आई होप इट हेल्प।
चलिए। अब यहां पे एक क्वेश्चन है। अ
पाकिस्तान में आपका एथिकल हैकिंग का कोर्स
बाय कैसे करें? सो इफ यू आर फ्रॉम
पाकिस्तान, सो आई एम एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
ब्रदर। वी हैव स्टॉप्ड टेकिंग एनरोलमेंट्स
फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान स्टूडेंट्स। तो हमने एक
टाइम के लिए पाकिस्तान के जितने भी
इनरोलमेंट्स हैं, हमारे फ्यूचर जितने भी
ट्रेनिंग कोर्सेज हैं, सबके लिए बंद कर
दिया है। एंड वी आर नॉट टेकिंग एनी
पाकिस्तानी स्टूडेंट्स एनीमोर। सो दैट्स
व्हाई यू कैन नॉट जॉइ ओके चलिए अ
देयर इज अ क्वेश्चन सर एi पेन टेस्टिंग
पढ़ना चाहिए या एआई का पूरा पढ़ना चाहिए एआई
पेन टेस्टिंग पढ़ो बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग बहुत
मजा आएगा राइट एआई पेन टेस्टिंग पढ़ो बहुत
ही यूज़फुल है
सर एआईडीएस ब्रांच लूं या दूसरी लूं क्या
आगे जॉब होंगे बिल्कुल होंगे यार ले लो ले
लो ले लो बिल्कुल ले लो हितेश यू शुड बी
टेकिंग द ब्रांच बिल्कुल ले लो। ठीक है।
एक क्वेश्चन है सर मेरे पास कोई डिग्री
नहीं है तो ईडब्ल्यूपीटी पे जॉब मिल
जाएगा। देखो डिग्री नहीं है और उस पे जॉब
मिलेगी कि नहीं ये डिपेंड करता है कंपनी
के ऊपर। राइट? ये मैं अगर आपको बोल भी दूं
कि हां तुम्हें जॉब मिल जाएगी। हां
तुम्हें डिग्री हां तुम्हें डिग्री
तुम्हें सॉरी सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी।
तुम्हें डिग्री नहीं भी है तो भी तुम्हें
जॉब मिल जाएगी। अगर मैं बोल दूं तो उससे
तो तुम्हें जॉब मिलेगी नहीं ना। तुम्हें
जॉब वही देगी जो कंपनी जो कंपनी को देनी
होगी। राइट? तो कंपनी का क्या पॉलिसी है?
किस तरीके से वो हायर कर रहे हो उस पे
डिपेंड करता है। अगर आपके बहुत सारी ऐसी
कंपनीज़ हैं जो डिग्री को उतना ज्यादा
मायने नहीं देती है वो आपको कंसीडर कर भी
सकती है। बट ऐसे बहुत कम कंपनीज़ हैं।
मोस्टली कंपनीज़ जो है वो डिग्री खोजती
हैं। दे वांट यू टू बी अ ग्रेजुएट।
इनफैक्ट दे वांट यू टू बी अ लाइक ग्रेजुएट
विद टेक्निकल बैकग्राउंड। एंड जब टेक्निकल
बैकग्राउंड से ग्रेजुएट करने का मतलब यह
होता है कि आपका बीटेक हो, बीएससीआईटी हो,
बीसीए हो, कुछ इस तरह की चीजें जो हैं अह
उसको मोस्टली जो है कंसीडर किया जाता है
इसमें। राइट?
ओके।
और जो कंपनी स्किल के बेसिस पे जॉब दे रही
है जस्ट गो एंड टेक इट। दैट्स इट। फिर तो
कोई मतलब ही नहीं है। कोई दिक्कत ही नहीं
है। कुछ क्वेश्चंस ऊपर थे। यहां पे ले
लेते हैं। अ
सर डीएई का क्या हुआ? डीएई की जो सीरीज की
वीडियोस है वो आएंगी। कुछ टाइम के लिए पॉज
किया गया था ड्यू टू द अनअवेलेबिलिटी ऑफ
योर ट्रेनर एंड कुछ इशूज़ हुए थे जिसकी वजह
से उसको पॉज किया गया था। बट बहुत जल्दी
जो है डीएई हमारी स्टार्ट होने वाली है।
राइट इज़ Android पे टेस्टिंग वर्थ? क्या
Android पे टेस्टिंग इतने बग्स होते हैं
कि मैंने 100% की तरफ जाऊं। नहीं 100% मत
जाओ। बट या इट्स वर्थ टू लर्न। Android पे
टेस्टिंग इज़ वर्थ टू लर्न। बट डोंट गो
100% इन एनीथिंग। एक्सपर्टाइज ले लो। ठीक
है? बट सिर्फ उसी पे डिपेंड मत रहो। दैट्स
इट।
सर कंप्लीटेड 40 लेक्चर्स इन बग बंटी ऑफ
बग बंटी इन 1.5 मंथ्स। मानस सिंह शर्मा
बहुत अच्छी बात है। कांग्रेचुलेशंस मानस
सिंह शर्मा आपने 40 लेक्चर्स को 1ढ़ महीने
में कंप्लीट किया। इट्स अ वेरी फैबुलस
थिंग। आई होप कि आपने कुछ अच्छा सीखा
होगा।
ओके।
जय हिंद सर। मैंने बग बंटी का कोर्स आपके
YouTube चैनल से करना शुरू कर दिया है।
काफी अच्छे तरीके से पढ़ाया आपने। थैंक्स
सर्वजीत जय हिंद एंड आप आपको अच्छा लग रहा
है सीखने में। कुछ मिल रहा है आपको तो
इससे बड़ी अच्छी चीज कुछ नहीं हो सकती है।
थैंक यू सो मच।
ओके।
यह क्वेश्चन
यहां पर क्वेश्चन है।
सर मेरे पास कोई डिग्री नहीं है सर। मेरे
पास कोई डिग्री नहीं है। तो डिग्री नहीं
है तो क्या दिक्कत है? स्किल गेन करो ना।
स्किल गेन करो ना। स्किल को गेन करो।
दैट्स इट।
राइट?
हेलो ब्रदर। हेलो। हेलो हेलो। चलिए आपके
कुछ और क्वेश्चंस हैं उनको ले लेते हैं जो
अभी रीसेंट क्वेश्चंस आए हैं उनके
क्वेश्चंस को हम यहां पे डील करते हैं।
कुछ अच्छे क्वेश्चंस पूछते हैं आप लोग तो
मुझे मजा आता है। कुछ अच्छे क्वेश्चंस
पूछो यार कुछ मजेदार क्वेश्चन पूछो।
हम
ओके
अगर जॉब नहीं मिल रही है इन एज अ
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट इसका मतलब है आपके
अंदर कुछ ना कुछ कमी है। जॉब्स हैं।
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट के पोजीशन के लिए
जॉब्स हैं। बहुत जॉब्स हैं। जाओ सर्च करो
Lindin पे आपको मिलेगा। फ्रेशर्स के लिए
भी है। बट आपके अंदर कुछ कमी है। कमी पता
है क्या है?
फर्स्ट कमी। जब आप फ्रेशर होते हैं तो यू
शुड बी ट्राइंग टू गेट एन इंटर्नशिप। आपको
6 महीने का एक इंटर्नशिप लेने की कोशिश
करनी चाहिए किसी कंपनी में। वो चाहे ऑन
साइट हो या रिमोट हो डजंट मैटर। बट एक
अच्छी इंटर्नशिप लेने की कोशिश करनी
चाहिए। जहां पे आपको यह नहीं देखना चाहिए
कि यू शुड बी गेटिंग पेड ऑ नॉट। वो अगर
आपके लिए पेड कर रहे हैं तो भी अच्छा है
ना पे कर रहे हो तो भी चलेगा। कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। बट यू शुड ट्राइंग टू गेट एन
इंटर्नशिप। उसी इंटर्नशिप के बेसिस पे
फ्रेशर्स को जज किया जाता है। एंड
फ्रेशर्स को जॉब दी जाती है। फर्जी
इंटर्नशिप करेंगे तो उसका कोई बेनिफिट
नहीं होगा। एंड एक्चुअल में आई एम टॉकिंग
अबाउट एक्चुअल इंटर्नशिप। उसको आपको आई
थिंक करना चाहिए। एंड वो स्किल आपके अंदर
फिर प्रॉपर होनी भी चाहिए। फिर यू कैन
डेफिनेटली गो एंड ओके दे यहां पे अ प्लीज
आप डोंट स्पैम हियर इन द चैट। अगर आप
स्पैम करेंगे तो आई हैव टू म्यूट यू। सो
प्लीज प्लीज डोंट स्पैम। मैं आपको
क्वेश्चन ले लेता हूं यहां पे बट यू शुड
नॉट स्पैम। भैया व्हाट इज़ द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन सीटीएफ एंड बग बंटी? बिकॉज़ आई हैव
सीटीएफ चैलेंजेस। सो यू कैन गाइड मी। अब
देखिए यहां पे डिफरेंस बिटवीन सीटीएफ एंड
वो कर रहे हैं। मैं यहां पे थोड़ी देर के
लिए इनको म्यूट कर रहा हूं 1 मिनट के लिए
जस्ट ताकि इनके मैसेजेस हट जाए। सीटीएफ
एंड बग बंटीज में क्या डिफरेंस है भैया?
तो दोनों में बहुत डिफरेंसेस हैं यार। दैट
इज अ थिंग कि आपके स्किल स्किल डेवलपमेंट
के लिए सीटीएफ आप करते हैं एंड यू जस्ट
शार्पेन योर स्किल्स। KTF जब आप कर रहे
होते हैं तो आपको आप अपनी स्किल्स को एक
प्रैक्टिकल मोड में शार्प शार्पन कर रहे
होते हैं। बग बाउंड्रीज़ में आप बग
बाउंड्रीज़ कर रहे होते हैं। बग्स ढूंढ रहे
होते हैं। एक्चुअल टारगेट के साथ इंटरेक्ट
कर रहे होते हैं। दैट्स इट। सीटीएफ में
वहां पे एक्चुअल टारगेट नहीं होते हैं।
वहां पे एक लैब एनवायरमेंट एक लैब
एनवायरमेंट एक ऑलरेडी सेटअप एनवायरमेंट के
अंदर काम कर रहे होते हैं। दैट्स इट। और
क्या? चलिए।
सर लो कंपटीशन बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम कैसे
फाइंड करें? शुड शुड बी ऑन रैंक
प्लेटफार्म हैकर वन Google डॉक का यूज़
कीजिए ट्रैक करते रहिए अलग-अलग डॉग्स के
लिए अलग-अलग रिजल्ट्स को एंड ट्राई करते
रहिए उनसे इंटैक्ट करने को एंड देन बग
क्राउड वगैरह पे जाइए बग क्राउड वगैरह
हैकर उन पे पहले जाने के लिए जाने की
कोशिश मत कीजिए ओपन बग बंटी जैसे
प्लेटफार्म को यूज़ कीजिए एंड जो लेस
पॉपुलर टारगेट्स हैं पहले उन पे हंट करने
की कोशिश कीजिए एंड दैट वुड बी गिविंग यू
सम कॉन्फिडेंस एंड उसी कॉन्फिडेंस के साथ
आप मोर पॉपुलर जो टारगेट्स है उस पे
सक्सेसफुली हंट कर पाएंगे। दैट्स इट। क्या
बात है। लाइक ठोका कि नहीं सबने? लाइक
नहीं ठोका ना यार। अच्छा लाइक ठोक दिया
सबने। वाह यार क्या बात है। कुछ लोगों ने
लाइक नहीं ठोका है। तो लाइक ठोक के जाना
है यार बस। लाइक ठोक के जाना है भाई। हम
ओके। यहां पे एक क्वेश्चन है। बॉस, आई एम
जीरो। बॉस, आई एम जीरो। तो ओके बॉस, आई एम
हीरो। हेलो सर। हेलो विनय कैसे हो? बढ़िया।
सर मेरे कॉलेज वाले जितना एक सेमेस्टर में
नहीं बता बताते उतना आप एक पार्ट में ही
बता देते हो। अरे रूट अहमद धन्यवाद।
धन्यवाद। ये तो बात सही है कि कि ज्यादा
ही बताता हूं मैं जो भी बताता हूं।
सर आपके Android पे टेस्टिंग में आईओएस
पढ़ाया गया है क्या? अरे भाई लोजंस यार
तुम्हें एक बात बताओ ट्रेनिंग है Android
पेंटेस्टिंग की राइट लिखा भी है कि
Android पेंटेस्टिंग ट्रेनिंग या डीसीएपी
एड Android पेंटेस्टर बनने का उसमें आईओएस
कहां से आ रहा है पहले ये बताओ मुझे iOS
की अगर होती तो उसका नाम भी iOS पेंटेस्टर
या iOS पेंटेस्टिंग की होती ना ब्रदर राइट
तो ये Android पेंटेस्टिंग में आईओएस कहां
से आ गया नहीं है ना यार ब्रदर नहीं है
उसमें समझे
हम
हां Android प्रिंटेस्टिंग होती है बस और
कुछ नहीं होता।
DCCI के लिए कोई हैकिंग नॉलेज नहीं चाहिए।
DCCI के लिए कोई हैकिंग नॉलेज चाहिए। नहीं
चाहिए आपको। DCCI में अगर आपको एनरोल करना
है जस्ट सिंपल सिंपल फंडा है आपको। आपको
यहां पे dfonic.com DCCI पे आ जाइएगा। का
अभी भी एनरोलमेंट चालू है। बट यहां पे
सिर्फ 10 सीट्स बचे हैं जो ऑफर फी में है
9000। अदरवाइज़ फी इज़ ₹1,000 एंड वो भी
आपको 92 इंस्टॉलमेंट्स में देने हैं। तो
यू कैन गो एंड यू कैन रीड ऑल द डिटेल्स।
यू कैन कम इन यहां पे नीचे एफए सेक्शन में
आ जाइएगा। फ्रीक्वेंटली आस्क क्वेश्चंस को
भी पढ़ लीजिएगा। आपके सारे सवालों के जवाब
मिल जाएंगे। 30 जुलाई से बैच स्टार्ट हो
रही है। थ्री मंथ्स का वीक डज़ ट्रेनिंग
होगा। मंडे, वेनेसडे, फ्राइडे एंड
वेरी-वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग ट्रेनिंग। यू शुड
डेफिनेटली जॉइन अगर आपको इस डोमेन में
करियर बनाना है या इस डोमेन में आपको कुछ
सीखना है तो राइट निशांत कुमावत भूल गए
मुझे नहीं बिल्कुल नहीं ऐसे कैसे भूल गए
ऐसे कैसे भूल गए
ओके
बग बाउंट साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्यूचर क्या
होगा सर अब अरे कुछ नहीं यार बग बाउंट
फ्यूचर साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्यूचर सब रहेगा
क्या हो गया फ्यूचर को क्या हो गया बताओ
इतना क्यों डर डर में हो तुम लोग डर में
क्यों हो आप लोग ये नहीं मुझे समझ नहीं
आता
है ना पता पता क्या पता जो एक्सबो आई है
आगे चलके उसी को हैक कर ले कोई पता चले
उसी में गड़बड़ हो जाए हु नोज़ राइट
ओके अर्पण इज़ आस्किंग सर मेरी ऐज 35 प्लस
है चलो आप तो यंग हैं अभी यार 35 प्लस का
मतलब क्या होता है 35 प्लस मींस यंग यंग
मैंने सीखा है मतलब मतलब किसी से कि आपकी
ऐज 40 भी हो 40 तक आप यंग हैं। मतलब लाइक
40 तक बस
तो टेंशन नहीं लेना है। 35 प्लस है और मैं
अभी
केपीओ जॉब करता हूं। क्या मुझे आफ्टर
वीएपीटी में जॉब मिल सकती है और मैं आपके
डीसीएपी कोर्स एनरोल्ड किया है बट मैं उसे
कंप्लीट नहीं कर पा रहा हूं कुछ इमरजेंसी
की वजह से। अच्छा अर्पण आपने डीसीएपी जॉइ
कर रखा है जो सेकंड बैच है। गुड।
डीसीएपीटी में अगर आप पूछना यह चाह रहे
हैं कि उसके बाद जॉब लगेगी वीएपीटी की तो
अगर आपका टेक्निकल बैकग्राउंड है तो
डेफिनेटली यू कैन गेट द जॉब बट अगर आपका
नॉनटेक बैकग्राउंड है तो थोड़ी मुश्किल
होगी बट दैट्स इट आप हमारे WhatsApp पे भी
कांटेक्ट कर लीजिएगा जो हमारी वेबसाइट पे
नंबर है वहां पे भी आपको और भी डिटेल अगर
कुछ जानकारी चाहिए होगी तो ठीक है
ओके कुछ और क्वेश्चंस लेते हैं यहां पे
सवाल का जवाब नहीं दिया कौन सा सवाल है
यार कुछ लोगों का सवाल रह जाता है वो बुरा
मत मानिएगा आप लोग। उसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी। हां। एक क्वेश्चन है सर गवर्नमेंट
में जॉब कैसे उसके लिए कौन सी एग्जाम होती
है? गवर्नमेंट में कौन सी जॉब लेनी है? ये
तो क्लियर करो कि जॉब कौन सी लेनी है? तुम
बोल रहे हो कि गवर्नमेंट में जॉब कैसे ले?
तो भाई ठीक है जॉब कैसे ले? अच्छी बात है।
बट कौन सी जॉब लेनी है? ये तो क्लियर करो।
तभी तो मैं बता पाऊंगा।
40 के सून। हां भाई आप लोगों की ये सब एक
सपोर्ट और जो प्यार है उसी का कमाल है कि
वी आर गोइंग टू रीच 40,000 सब्सक्राइबर
मार्क्स एंड आई थिंक कि बहुत जल्द यह
कंप्लीट भी हो जाएगा 40,000्राइबर मार्क
चैट मिस नहीं है यार निशार्ग मैंने अब बता
दिया आपको बोला भी मैंने आपको और आपके
Lindin पोस्ट पे भी मैंने किया
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू निशार्ग फॉर गेटिंग
सिलेक्टेड सो आपका Lindin पोस्ट भी अगर
भूल गया होता तो कैसे
ओके ब्रो हाउ डू यू वर्क इन साइबर सेल
लाइक आई हैव ओसिएंट एंड मोर स्किल्स सो आई
डायरेक्टली कांटेक्ट पुलि टू पुलिस कैन यू
टेल मी जस्ट आस्किंग ब्रो आई एम फुल टाइम
हंटर ओके नौसिकिया सबसे पहले तो इफ यू हैव
द ओसेंट स्किल देन यू आर ट्रूली गुड फॉर द
साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन रोल एंड
ऑब्वियस सी बात है इसके अप्रोचेस होते हैं
अलग-अलग तरीके के लाइक आपको पुलिस में ही
अप्रोच करना पड़ता है या फिर कोई कांटेक्ट
है तो उसके थ्रू आप जा सकते हैं। पुलिस
में अप्रोच करके आप अपनी स्किल्स शो करके
उनके लिए प्रोएक्टिवली काम करने की एक
अपनी इच्छा जाहिर करनी है बिना पैसे के
सोचे हुए। एंड जब उनको आपका काम अच्छा
लगेगा दे कैन हायर यू ऑन कॉन्ट्रैक्ट
बेसिस। कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बेसिस पे हायरिंग होती
है। या तो अगर आप पुलिस डिपार्टमेंट में
ही जॉब करना चाहते हैं लाइक तो आप फिर जो
नॉर्मल जो इंस्पेक्टर या जो भी एग्जाम्स
वगैरह होते हैं पुलिस डिपार्टमेंट की या
एसीपी रैंक की आप उसमें जाके फिर वहां से
स्विच कर सकते हैं। आप यू कैन बी बिकम हेड
ऑफ द साइबर सेल और ऐसे करके आप उसको ऑपरेट
भी कर सकते हैं। ऐसा भी होता है। सर आप
आईपीएस क्यों नहीं बने? क्यों मैं आईपीएस
तुम्हें चाहिए कि मैं आईपीएस बनूं? आपको
एिमी वीडियो करके जो है आप आईपीएस मुझे
बनाना चाहते हैं। क्यों बनाना चाहते हैं
आप आईपीएस? बनने का तो मेरा भी मन है बट
बन नहीं पाया।
ओके
विनय इज़ आस्किंग हेलो नितेश सर, आई एम
फ्रॉम डीसीएपीटी बैच। दिस इज़ वेरी वेरी
दिस इज़ वेरी ग्रेट क्लास एंड कांसेप्ट
पूरा क्लियर हो गया मेरा। फुल वीएपीटी
प्रोसेस
कैसे करना होता है? थैंक यू। विनय
महेंद्र। सो थैंक यू विनय। एंड आई एम
ग्लैड कि आपको काफी अच्छा लगा डीसीएपीटी
क्योंकि अभी ये बैच खत्म हो चुकी है
ऑलमोस्ट। तो अ मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि यू
गाइस हैव लर्न वेल एंड आपने काफी कुछ सीखा
है एंड एक्चुअल जो एक जॉब ओरिएंटेड
ट्रेनिंग होती है उसके हिसाब से इंडस्ट्री
रेलेवेंट चीजें सीखी है। सो थैंक्स। ओके।
यहां पे कुछ क्वेश्चंस और हैं जो हम लेते
हैं यहां पे। अ बाय सर यू आर नॉट
रिप्लाइंग। भाई मैसेज ही नहीं देखा ना
आपका। मैसेज कुछ लोगों का रह जाता है। मैं
क्या बोलूं? अब जो कुछ लोगों का मैसेज रह
जाता है। मैं रिप्लाई नहीं करता हूं तो
बोलते हैं बाय। अब बताओ मेरी क्या गलती है
इसमें? हम
दो-तीन बार पूछ लो ना। बहुत सारे देखो
बहुत सारे मैसेज आपके सामने हैं बट कुछ का
रह जाता है।
ओके। एक क्वेश्चन है सेंस का जो बाय कर
रहे थे अभी। जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस मैं एक चीज
स्टार्ट कर दूं। जस्ट अ से जस्ट अ सेकंड।
जस्ट अ सेकंड। जस्ट अ सेकंड।
हम
ओके चलिए सो बेसिकली आई वास स्टार्टिंग अ
बैच एक बैच थी उसको स्टार्ट करनी थी। सो
आई स्टार्टेड इट राइट। ओके।
चलिए तो अगेन क्वेश्चंस लेते हैं।
ओके अगेन क्वेश्चंस लेते हैं यहां पे। तो
यहां पे क्वेश्चन है जिनका रह गया था। सर
लाइक मुझे बहुत कुछ पता है और मैंने
सीडीएफ चैलेंज भी बहुत किया है और बहुत
कुछ सीखा पर रियल साइड में मुझसे नहीं हो
रहा है। मैं कैसे करूं प्लीज गाइड मी? सो
ये बहुत बड़ा क्वेश्चन है। साइंस का
क्वेश्चन है। एंड ये काफी लोगों का सेम
क्वेश्चन होता है कि सीटीएफ में अच्छा कर
रहा हूं। रियल वेबसाइट पे अच्छा नहीं कर
पा रहा हूं। एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा राइट अब
मैं आपको एक चीज़ बताता हूं। राइट? एक एक
चीज़ आपको समझाता हूं। जब भी आप सीटीएफ
करते हैं या लैब्स पे सॉल्व करते हैं जो
भी आपकी टेक्निक होती है उस सेम टेक्निक
को यूज़ करना है आपको लाइव जो बैचेस लाइव
जो आपकी वेबसाइट्स होती है ना मेथोडोलॉजीस
को चेंज करते रहना है अलग-अलग मेथड सीटीएफ
में आपने करा एक ही पर्टिकुलर चीज एक ही
तरीके से आपको एक चीज फ्लैग मिल गई या एक
जो है फाइंडिंग आपने कर ली लेकिन जब आप बग
बाउंट रियल वेबसाइट पे करते हैं रियल
टारगेट पे ना तो आपको वहां पे
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ यूज़ लाइक अह
मेथोडोलॉजीज़ अप्लाई करने पड़ते हैं। अरे
हां ऐसे नहीं मिला तो वैसे वैसे नहीं मिला
तो ऐसे इस तरीके से करके यू हैव टू अप्लाई
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ मेथोडोलॉजीस एंड
वो मेथोडोलॉजीस जितनी आप चेंज करेंगे और
जो मेथोडोलॉजी आपकी सक्सेसफुल रहती है यू
जस्ट हैव टू अप्लाई दैट पर्टिकुलर
मेथोडोलॉजी एंड जैसे ही आप अप्लाई कर दोगे
यू आर गुड टू गो एंड आपके लिए वो बढ़िया
एक अप्रोच हो जाएगी बस ये चीज होता है
इसलिए रियल टारगेट पे जल्दी बग्स नहीं
मिलते हैं एंड सीटीएफ्स में आप ईजीली
कम्पीट कर पाते हो क्योंकि सीटीएफ में एक
स्ट्रेट फॉरवर्ड पहले से प्री कॉन्फ़िगर्ड
एनवायरमेंट के अंदर एक प्री कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड
एक स्टेप होती है जिसको फॉलो कर लिया तो
आपको फ्लैग मिल जाएगा। रियल टारगेट पैसा
पहले से कुछ भी कॉन्फ़िगर नहीं होता। कुछ
भी हो सकता है। आपको कुछ भी मिल सकता है।
किसी भी तरह की चैलेंजज़ मिल सकती है। उन
चैलेंजज़ को ओवरकम करने में आपको जो है वो
आपको अलग-अलग मेथोडोलॉजीज़ अपनाने पड़ते
हैं। एक तरीका अपनाया उससे नहीं हुआ।
दूसरा तरीका अपनाया, तीसरा तरीका अपनाया।
अब एक जगह आपको 401 एरर मिलती है तो आपको
उसको बाईपास अगर करना है तो यू हैव टू
ट्राई डिफरेंट मेथड्स राइट आपको अलग-अलग
मेथड्स ट्राई करने पड़ेंगे तो तभी जाके वो
आप सक्सेसफुल आप उसको बना पाएंगे राइट
चलिए
ओके देयर इज़ सम मोर क्वेश्चंस लेट्स टेक
सम क्वेश्चंस सर प्लीज ईडब्ल्यूपीटी
एग्जाम को सक्सेसफुली क्लियर करने के लिए
किन चीजों को ज्यादा फोकस करें अ देखो
ईडब्ल्यूपीटी का मैं आपको गिटब देखो गिट
आप Google पे जाना सर्च कर लेना
ईडब्ल्यूपीटी
नोट्स ऐसे गिट करके लिख देना ईडब्ल्यूपीटी
रिसोर्सेज गिट करके लिख देना आपको गिट के
बहुत सारे रिसोर्सेज मिल जाएंगे जो
ईडब्ल्यूपीटी के लिए स्पेशली डेडिकेटेड है
पूरे स्टेप वाइज आपको मिल जाएंगे या बहुत
सारे जो ईडब्ल्यूपीटी क्लियर्ड जो
जिन्होंने ईडब्ल्यूपीटी क्लियर किया है इस
सर्टिफिकेशन को बहुत सारे ऐसे लोग होते
हैं उनको फाइंड कीजिए उनके खुद के भी
स्टेप्स पूरे प्रोसेस उन्होंने जो है वो
कलेक्ट करके रखा रहता है गेटअप वगैरह पे
उन्होंने डाला हुआ रहता है तो आप उसको भी
फॉलो कर सकते हैं राइट राइट
ओके सर एक्सबो क्या बग बंटी हंटर की जॉब
को डिस्ट्रॉय कर देगा कभी नहीं करेगा कुछ
नहीं करेगा टेंशन मत लो यार इतना दिमाग को
मत खराब करो एक्सबो को लेके एक्सबो अपना
काम करेगा तुम अपना काम करो एक्सबो को
करने दो जो कर रहा है आप अपने काम पे भिड़े
रहिए ठीक है प्लीज डोंट गेट कैरिड अवे बाय
एक्सबो उससे मत घबराइए आप अपना काम कीजिए
लर्निंग स्किल पे फोकस कीजिए उसके अलावा
कुछ मत कीजिए हव के पीछे मत भागिए कि लोग
मतलब यह वो वो ऐसे हो जाएगा ना नो
एक्चुअली आई एम अ फुल टाइम हंटर आई लव
इन्वेस्टिगेशन दैट्स व्हाई आई एम सेइंग
दैट लाइक आई हैव टाइम इशू बिजी इन गेटिंग
बंटीज हा
ओके ओके नो ब्रदर ही इज़ नॉट पार्ट ऑफ़
डिफ्रॉनिक्स नाउ एनीमोर
सो वी हैव टर्मिनेटेड हिम ओके
ओके
सो सम मोर क्वेश्चंस हियर
सर नेक्स्ट क्लास कौन सी आएगी? बग बंटी की
ही क्लास आएगी। नेक्स्ट क्लास बहुत जल्द
आएगी।
निशार्ग इस सेइंग थैंक यू सर जी। सब आपकी
वजह से है क्योंकि मैंने अपने करियर की
शुरुआत आपके यहां से ही किया है और आज यह
पोजीशन पर हूं। सबका क्रेडिट आपको एंड
थैंक्स टू यू। थैंक्स निसार्ग। थैंक यू
फॉर योर गुड वर्ड्स हियर। इतना अच्छा आपने
बोला है। सो इट्स
इट्स इट्स रियली प्राउड टू हैव अ लर्नर
लाइक यू एंड अदर्स जो आपके जैसे हैं। तो
आपको एक्चुअली मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशंस
फॉर गेटिंग टू दैट पर्टिकुलर लेवल। तो आप
अच्छा कीजिए करियर में ऑल द बेस्ट।
सर डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स का भी कोर्स लाओगे?
हां बिल्कुल आएंगे। लिस्ट ऑफ़ फाइनेंसिस की
भी ट्रेनिंग आने वाली है। बहुत जल्द आने
वाली है।
वेल डूड योर बिग ब्रदर इज डीएसपी राइट। यस
यस ब्रदर। यस एसीपी रैंक है डीएसपी। यस
राइट
करेक्ट।
एक्सबो ने 75% ही किया है। हमारे पास फिर
भी 25% है उसके साथ कमपीट करने के लिए।
बिल्कुल। एक्सबो ने 75% किया है। ये बोल
रहे हैं। किया तो 70% ही होगा। 30% आपके
पास है। एंड यू हैव ह्यूमन ब्रेन रादर देन
एन एआई और आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस और
मशीन। सो आपका दिमाग हमेशा उनसे आगे है।
याद रखिएगा ये चीज। ह्यूमंस आर ऑलवेज
सुपीरियर।
ओके देयर इज़ अ क्वेश्चन। सर मुझे स्टडी
अब्रॉड का ड्रीम है। क्या मुझे जेईई देना
चाहिए? बिल्कुल दे दीजिए आप। बिल्कुल दे
सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है आपको। अगर
अब्रॉड का ड्रीम है, यू कैन डेफिनेटली
गिव।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। उससे कोई इशू नहीं है।
यू कैन डेफिनेटली गिव।
ओके।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल।
यहां पे कुछ और क्वेश्चंस हैं। उनको ले
लेते हैं यहां पे। अ सर यू सर यू इग्नर्ड
माय लास्ट योर क्वेश्चन अगेन। अरे यार मैं
कौन सी क्वेश्चन इग्नोर कर दे रहा हूं।
किसका कर दे रहा हूं पता ही नहीं चल रहा।
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी ब्रदर इफ आई इग्नोर योर
क्वेश्चंस
बिकॉज़ मुझे एक्चुअली खोजना पड़ेगा कि आपके
कौन से क्वेश्चंस थे। ठीक है? एक क्वेश्चन
है यहां पे लर्न वि काजम्मिका। सर प्लीज
आंसर मी हाउ टू अप्रोच फॉर एक्सेस? आई हैव
ट्राइड हाउ टू फाइंड साइट वनरेबल टू
एक्सेस? इट इज़ 10 टाइम हैं। 10 टाइम सर आई
एम आस्किंग। हाउ टू अप्रोच फॉर एक्सेस? अब
देखो एक्सेस के लिए कैसे अप्रोच करना है।
मैं आपको एक बात बताता हूं। आप लोग ना सही
से ना तो देखते हो वीडियोस ना तो आप सीखते
हो। मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि यू गाइस डोंट इन
एक्चुअल
ट्राई टू लर्न द मेन थिंग। आपको मुझे ऐसा
लगता है कि आप मेन चीज ना सीखना नहीं
चाहते। आपको चाहिए सब कुछ एक साथ रखा हुआ।
तो सब कुछ एक साथ रख के भी दे रहा हूं
मैं। बट स्टिल क्या है वो आप सीखने के लिए
तैयार नहीं है। तो मैं आपको यहां पे फिर
भी स्टिल आई एम गोइंग टू टेल यू एंड आई एम
गोइंग टू लेट यू नो। आपको एक्सेस के बारे
में बहुत अच्छे से जानकारी लेनी है। मैं
आपको बोलूंगा आप प्लेलिस्ट में जाइएगा
यहां पे और डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube
चैनल पे व्यू प्लेलिस्ट पे जाइएगा। कैसे
फाइंड करना है? क्या सब आपको इसमें मिल
जाएगा। नीचे की तरफ थोड़ा स्क्रॉल करते
जाइएगा। थोड़ा यहां पे आपको एक वीडियो
मिलेगी डे 18 की, डे 19 की। इन दोनों को
देख लीजिएगा। अच्छे से देख लीजिएगा। 2ाई
घंटे की ये वीडियो है। 2 घंटे की 4 1/2
घंटे की वीडियो है। एक अपने आप में एक
शॉर्ट कोर्स टाइप के हैं ये वीडियोस। एक
अपने आप में एक क्रैश कोर्स टाइप की चीजें
हैं। उनको देख लीजिएगा।
अभी किसी ने साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
में एनरोल किया है।
ओके। बढ़िया है। बढ़िया है। पता नहीं आप
में से ही होंगे शायद। ओके। ठीक है।
नेक्स्ट क्लास कौन सी होगी बताएंगे।
ओके ओके
ओके सो कुछ क्वेश्चंस ले लेते हैं यहां पे
अरे एक्सबो कुछ नहीं करेगा यार एक्सो
एक्सबो कुछ नहीं करेगा क्यों एक्सबो को
एक्सबो को ले इतना टेंशन में हो यार
एक्सबो को ले इतना टेंशन में मत रहो
एक्सबो को लेके इतना टेंशन में रहोगे तो
दिक्कत हो जाएगी। मैं आपको क्लियर बता
देता हूं। डोंट गेट कैरिड अवे विद द हाइप
ऑफ एक्सबो। अपनी स्किल पे फोकस करो। इसके
लिए वीडियो लेकर आनी ही पड़ेगी। मुझे लगता
है बढ़िया वाली। तभी आप लोगों को शायद समझ
में आएगा।
सर आपके YouTube वीडियोस बाद में जाके
प्रीमियम कोर्सर्सेस में ऐड हो जाएंगे
क्या? बिल्कुल हो सकते हैं। पॉसिबिलिटी
पॉसिबिलिटीज़ आर देयर। बिल्कुल हो सकते
हैं। हम ऐसा कर सकते हैं। देखिए मैं आपको
बता देता हूं। आई एम जस्ट लेटिंग यू नो
गाइस। हम इसमें जो वीडियोस हैं जो बग
बाउंट के वीडियोस आ रहे हैं यहां पे। ठीक
है? जैसे ये वीडियोस आ गए मान लो। ठीक है?
ये वीडियोस आ गए। आपको यहां पे दिख रहा है
ये वीडियोस। अब मैं ऐसा भी कर सकता हूं कि
दीज़ आई कैन मेक दीज़ वीडियोज़ लाइक आपके
स्टार्टिंग के 10 वीडियोज़ आपके लिए यहां
पे अवेलेबल रहेंगे। स्टार्टिंग के 10
वीडियोस विल बी अवेलेबल फॉर एवरीबॉडी द डे
या डे 15 तक। चलो यार डे 20 तक रहेंगे।
मान लो डे 20 तक रहेंगे अवेलेबल। उसके बाद
ये जो वीडियोस हैं ये मेंबर्स ओनली
वीडियोस हम कर देंगे। यानी कि जो मेंबर्स
होंगे जो लाइक वही देख पाएंगे इन वीडियोस
को। तो ऐसा भी पॉसिबबली हो सकता है। तो आप
इसको अभी जब मौका है फ्री में इतनी कुछ
सीखने का फ्री में मैं आपको दे रहा हूं तो
आप सीखिए ना व्हाई यू आर नॉट लर्निंग
दैट्स इट। व्हाई यू आर नॉट टेकिंग द
अपोरर्चुनिटी
आप महाराष्ट्र से हो क्या? नहीं भाई मैं
महाराष्ट्र से नहीं हूं। मैं ओरिजिनली
बिहार से हूं। बट करेंटली आई एम इन दिल्ली
एनसीआर राइट दिल्ली एनसीआर गाजियाबाद।
सर मैं एथ में हूं। ट्राई हैक में टॉप टू
में हूं। आगे क्या करूं? भाई तुम एथ क्लास
में हो और ट्राई हैक पे अगर टॉप टू में आ
गए हो तो आगे क्या ही करना है? आगे कुछ मत
करो। तुम बस सीखते जाओ। लर्निंग स्किल्स
गेन करते जाओ। तुम अपनी लर्निंग को
कंटिन्यू रखो। इतना काफी है। एथ क्लास में
अगर तुम टॉप टू में हो तो अब तुम्हें कुछ
नहीं चाहिए भाई। लेट्स कीप लर्निंग।
सर प्लीज इसको फ्री रहना मेंबर्स के लिए
ना रखना बस तो अभी तो यार फ्री है ना तो
आप लोग अभी क्यों नहीं अभी वीडियोस को
देखो ना प्रैक्टिस करो देखो प्रैक्टिस करो
व्हाई यू आर नॉट लर्निंग मैं ये नहीं समझ
पाता हूं
आपका चैनल थोड़े दिन पहले मिला ठीक है मैं
अभी तो नहीं कर रहा हूं मेंबर ओनली मैं
अभी नहीं कर रहा हूं मतलब अभी टाइम है
2026 में शायद कर दूं शायद तो प्लीज
कंटिन्यू टू वॉच देखते जाइए ना देखते जाइए
करते जाइए
अभी तो मैं नहीं कर रहा यार अभी नहीं आई
एम नॉट डूइंग राइट अवे
मैं एमसीए डेवलपमेंट बैकग्राउंड से था।
फिर मैंने डिसाइड किया करियर स्विच करने
का। सो मैं सो मैं सारे आपके वीडियोस फॉलो
किया। फाइव मंथ्स हुए
और इंटर्नशिप भी कर लिया और एक्सटेंड भी
हुई। अ एंड अभी हॉल ऑफ फेम मिले। क्या बात
है आयुष कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू यू फॉर दिस
काइंड ऑफ़ स्विच एंड दिस काइंड ऑफ़ टर्न
अराउंड जो आपने किया है। वो काफी अच्छा
है। एंड आपको सक्सेस सक्सेस मिला है। यह
अपने आप में बड़ी बात है। सो मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशंस एंड ऑल द बेस्ट फॉर योर
करियर।
वेल योर मेन एम मेन एरिया इज फॉरेंसिक्स
राइट आई सॉ अ गुड एट फॉरेंसिक्स ऐसा कुछ
नहीं है। मेरा कोई मेन एरिया नहीं है। सब
एरिया मेरे खुद के हैं। एंड सारा टॉपिक
सारा डोमेन मेरा है। सो मैं सारे डोमेन का
मैं हूं। एंड मुझे काफी अच्छा लगता है।
पूरी साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन चाहे वो किसी
भी पर्टिकुलर डोमेन की बात हो रही हो। एक
महीने में कंप्लीट कर दूंगा। बहुत बहुत
अच्छी बात है हितेश। करो एक महीने में
करो। सर i7 8GB रैम 2GB ग्राफिक्स कार्ड
सही है। हां बिगिनर्स के लिए बिगिनिंग के
लिए स्टार्टिंग के लिए सही है। बहुत अच्छी
है। 8GB रैम इज गुड। 8 GB का और लगा लेना
बाद में 16 GB कर लेना एक खरीद के बाहर
से। 2GB ग्राफिक्स आज के टाइम में इज़
नॉर्मल। 4 GB होता तो बेटर होता। बट ठीक
है। i7 भी ले रहे हो तो 13th जनरेशन या
उसके ऊपर का लेना कोशिश करना। उसके ऊपर का
हो तो बेटर है। 13 बाउंड डन। 13 बाउंड डन।
क्या बात है? वि 50 मोर
विल हिट 50 मोर प्लस थैंक्स वाओ क्या बात
है गुड बहुत अच्छी बात है नौसिकिया
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू फॉर गेटिंग दिस
बंटीज
ओके वेलकम आयुष साइबर टेक अजू इज़ आस्किंग
सर मैंने Google जेमिनाई के अंदर एलएलएम
प्र्प इंजेक्शन फाइंड किया है एंड रिपोर्ट
भी कर दिया है और ट्रिगर भी हो गया सर
जल्दी आपको Lindin पर मेंशन करूंगा क्या
बात है Google जेमिनाई साइबर टेक अ जू
थैंक यू एंड कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू फॉर
फाइंडिंग द प्र्प इंजेक्शन इन लाइक Google
जेमिनाई एंड अगर वो बंटी वगैरह मिलती है
या कुछ भी होता है तो प्लीज लेट मी नो एंड
प्लीज पोस्ट ऑन द Lindin एंड टैग
डेफ्रोनिक्स सो रियली अ वेरी प्राउड ऑन
पीपल लाइक यू जो हार नहीं मानते हैं लगे
रहते हैं लगे रहते हैं करते रहते हैं
प्रैक्टिस करते रहते हैं उनप मैं प्राउड
फील करता हूं एंड आई एम ऑलवेज देयर फॉर
देम डेफ्रोनिक्स इज़ इज़ ऑलवेज देयर फॉर
देम। डेफ़्रोनिक्स हमेशा उन सब लोगों के
लिए अवेलेबल रहेगा। बस आपसे एक चीज़ मैं
जरूर चाहूंगा हमेशा कि आप Lindin पे जब भी
पोस्ट करें तो प्लीज टैग कीजिए हमें। हमें
भी पता चले कि आपका क्या चल रहा है, क्या
प्रोसेस है, क्या प्रोग्रेस है। एंड
वीडियोस को शेयर कर दीजिए अपने ग्रुप्स
में। हमें और कुछ नहीं चाहिए होता है। आप
चाहे जो करना है कीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है। आप सीखते रहिए और वीडियोस को शेयर
कीजिए। वीडियोस को जितना शेयर करेंगे
हमारी रीच उतनी बढ़ेगी। लोगों तक उतनी
पहुंचेगी। लोगों को उतना नॉलेज फ्री में
एक्चुअल नॉलेज क्वालिटी नॉलेज मिलेगी। सो
जस्ट कीप लर्निंग एंड कीप डूइंग दिस
थिंग्स। थैंक यू। ओके।
सर आपको कितना टाइम लगा कंप्लीट एथिकल
हैकर बनने में? कंप्लीट एथिकल हैकर तो पता
नहीं क्या होता है। अह मैं ऐसी टर्म्स पे
बिलीव नहीं करता। नोबडी कैन बिकम अ
कंप्लीट एथिकल हैकर। जस्ट एन एथिकल हैकर।
प्रोफेशनल एथिकल हैकर। या बेस्ट यू कैन डू
से योरसेल्फ कि हां मैं एक बहुत अच्छा
एथिकल हैकर बन चुका हूं। दैट्स इट।
रेट लिमिट वनेबिलिटी जनरली आउट ऑफ स्कोप
होती है। रेट लिमिट को बाईपास अगर कर पाते
हैं आप किसी भी तरीके से तो फिर वो
एक्सेप्ट की जाती है। तो ट्राई टू बाईपास
रेट लिमिट वनेबिलिटीज।
यू रिमेंबर मी आई एम पैराडॉक्स हंट आई टैग
यू टू ए हे यस यस यस आई डू रिमेंबर ब्रदर
डू रिमेंबर
आई डू रिमेंबर
ग्रेट साइबर टेक वेलकम एंड मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशंस मतलब रियली आपके आपका यह
बहुत मुझे लगता है कि बहुत एक प्राउड
मोमेंट है मेरे लिए भी क्योंकि आई नो यू
आर फॉलोइंग मी फ्रॉम वेरी लॉन्ग टाइम मैं
आपको कई बार देख चुका हूं लाइव में भी।
एंड इफ यू आर हंटिंग दीज़ थिंग्स देन दैट्स
गुड। आप ऐसे ही जाइए। बस यही है कि लोग
लोगों को अपना जो स्टाइल है, अपना जो नेचर
है, उसको बदलना नहीं चाहिए। आप जिस तरीके
की सोच अभी रखते हैं, वैसा ही हमेशा रखना
चाहिए आपको। आपको बदलना नहीं चाहिए। यू
डोंट हैव टू बी चेंज्ड पर्सन। ऐसा नहीं कि
अब आपने बग बाउंट सीख ली। आपने बहुत स्किल
गेन कर लिया। आप बहुत अच्छे लेवल पर चले
गए। तो आपके अंदर वो एक ईगो और घमंड नहीं
आनी चाहिए। आपके अंदर वो अगर आ गई तो
नोबडी कैन गिव यू सक्सेस। फिर आपको ना वो
आगे बढ़ने से रोक देगी। याद रखिएगा ये
चीज। तो जब भी आपके अंदर जितना भी नॉलेज
स्किल आ जाए आप चाहे Google के टॉप हॉल ऑफ
फेम में क्यों ना चले जाएं। यू शुड ऑलवेज
रिमेंबर योर रूट एंड ऑलवेज रिमेंबर कि आप
कहां से कैसे कहां से आए हैं और किन चीजों
से होते हुए आए हैं। एंड आपको घमंड नहीं
होना चाहिए। यू शुड बी वेरी पोलाइट वेरी
पंकुअल काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग पोलाइट काइंड ऑफ़
पर्सन ऑलवेज चाहे आप किसी भी लेवल पे कुछ
लोग क्या होते हैं आजकल मैंने देखा है कई
लोगों को देखा है कि बग बंटीज बेसिक से
सीखना शुरू करते हैं। काफी अच्छा सीख भी
लेते हैं। काफी अच्छा करने भी लगते हैं।
लेट्स सपोज कि हां काफी अच्छा कर रहे हैं।
बट एट द सेम टाइम क्या होता है कि वो बहुत
ज्यादा रूढ़ टाइप हो जाते हैं। दूसरों को
रिप्लाई देना बंद कर देते हैं। दूसरों को
हेल्प करना बंद कर देते हैं। उनको लगता है
कि अरे भैया अब तो मैं क्यों दूसरों की
हेल्प करूं? मतलब इतनी बड़ी चीज हो जाती
है ना जो मैं जो बहुत अजीब सा हो जाता है।
एंड उनको लगता है कि लाइक अगर कहीं पे
रिप्लाई नहीं करेंगे तो वो बड़े इंसान हो
जाएंगे। ऐसा नहीं होता है। इट्स मेकिंग यू
अ शॉर्टर इंस्टेड ऑफ़ बिगर। तो आपको छोटा
इंसान बना रहा है। बड़ा नहीं बना रहा है।
स्मॉलर यू आर गेटिंग स्मॉलर डे बाय डे।
नॉट बिगर शॉर्टर नहीं स्मॉलर। यू शुड बी
ऑलवेज कीपिंग इन दिस माइंड।
सर आपके बग बंटी क्लास को लेकर अभी
बहुत अच्छा बोल रहे थे सर मुझे बहुत अच्छा
लगा अच्छा अच्छा थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू
लोजेंस ब्रदर थैंक यू
यस बेसिकली अंश इज़ माय फ्रेंड माय वन ऑफ़
वन ऑफ़ माय गुड फ्रेंड जो लोजेंस आपने बोला
ना कि अंश भी बोल रहा था अच्छा तो अंश इज़
वन ऑफ़ माय वेरी गुड फ्रेंड ऑब्वियस सी बात
है कि हम रियल लाइफ में नहीं मिले हैं। बट
बट डेफिनेटली वुड बी मीटिंग सम डे एंड
काफी अच्छे हम दोस्त भी हैं। तो दैट्स
व्हाई ही माइट बी सेइंग। सो आई मस्ट
अप्रिशिएट हिम आल्सो फॉर कंट्रीब्यूटिंग
टू साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड ऑल जो भी है। सो
थैंक्स।
ओके।
यस नौ सीखिए आप रिप्लाई करते होंगे।
बिल्कुल सही है।
ओके।
अच्छा आप लोगों में से कितने लोगों को
मेरा नाम पता है? मुझे बता दीजिए। कितने
लोगों को मेरा नाम पता है? जरा बताइए जरा।
देखते हैं। लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू नो
माय नेम। एक्चुअल में
लेट मी नोबडी।
कितने लोगों को मेरा नाम पता है?
तभी सच्चाई सामने आएगी।
एक नितेश सोनी बोल रहा है। कौन है भाई
सिंह करके? हट नितेश सोनी कौन है? नितेश
सोनी नहीं है मेरा नाम यार। नितेश सिंह
हां नितेश सिंह नाम है। ओके ठीक है।
बढ़िया काफी लोगों को पता है। क्या बात
है। थैंक यू।
थैंक यू। थैंक यू। चलिए अच्छी बात है। अरे
रैना देखो ये बोल रहा है नितेश रैना। ये
कौन सी बात है? नितेश रैना। नितेश रैना
मेरा नाम नहीं है भाई नितेश सिंह नाम है
मेरा
हम
देखो ये लर्न वि काजमी नितेश सिंह अरे
नितेश आल्सो नोन एस टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
बिल्कुल सही बोला आपने साइबर टेक जी
धन्यवाद चलिए अच्छी बात है
अच्छी बात है बढ़िया
ओके हां एक और है हमारी Instagram की जो
पेज है वो तो अब ये हो गई है। मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं। Instagram.com dfनिक्स aca
एकडमी। नाउ इट हैज़ बिकम दिस वन। सो मैं
यहां पे आपको दिखा देता हूं। करके ऐसे ओपन
करके दिखा देता हूं। सो इट्स नाउ
Instagram.com dfonics academy। यह हमारा
यूजरनेम हो चुका है। सो वी हैव चेंज्ड टू
दिस। सो dfonic accडमी सर्च करेंगे। आपको
हमको आपको हमारा Instagram पेज दिखेगा
जहां 50 प्लस 50,000 प्लस फॉलोवर्स जो है
हमारे यहां पे अवेलेबल हैं। राइट? एंड
Twitter पे भी हमारे जो अभी Twitter पे जो
अ पेज है वो है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी इस पे
आप जाएंगे
तो आप डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी के Twitter हैंडल
पे आ जाएंगे एंड दिस इज़ दैट दिस इज़ दिस
राइट सो यहां पे पोस्ट में आपको यहां
मिलेगा हैज़ नॉट पोस्टेड येट बट ऐसा नहीं
है पोस्ट हुआ है बट ये पता नहीं क्यों
नहीं शो कर रहा है शायद लॉग इन करने के
बाद शो करेगा सो यू कैन जस्ट से योरसेल्फ
राइट चलिए यहां पे कुछ क्वेश्चंस है उसको
भी लेके देन हम एंड करते हैं सेशन को
सर यू इग्नोरिंग मी? अरे मैं किसी को
इग्नोर नहीं करता भाई। मुझे आपसे कोई
पर्सनली दुश्मनी थोड़ी ना है कि मैं आपको
इग्नोर करूंगा। कुछ क्वेश्चन छूट जाते हैं
बस। दैट्स इट।
सर आपने टेक्निकल नेविगेटर से डिफ्रॉनिक्स
पर क्यों शिफ्ट किया? बल्कि उसमें ज्यादा
सब्सक्राइबर्स हैं। सब्सक्राइबर्स की बात
नहीं है। डिफ्रॉनिक्स इज़ आवर ओन कंपनी एंड
अ स्टार्टअप। सो वी जस्ट वांट टू फोकस मोर
ऑन दिस एंड वी वांट टू ग्रो इट ऑन अ मच
लार्जर स्केल। दैट्स व्हाई
डू यू हैव? हां जी है भाई मेरे पास है
सर्टिफिकेशन।
ठीक है गाइस। सो मोस्टली सारे जो हैं अ
क्वेश्चंस आपके ले लिए गए हैं। आप बिहार
में कहां से हो? ईस्ट चंपारण डिस्ट्रिक्ट
से हूं मैं। मोस्टली आपके सारे क्वेश्चंस
जो है मैंने ले लिए हैं। एंड मोस्ट ऑफ द
क्वेश्चंस आर आंसर्ड ऑफ योर्स। सो आई होप
कि आपको जो भी सवाल थे आपके उसके जवाब
मिले हैं। एंड
यू गॉट द आंसर राइट? तो जाने से पहले यहां
पे लाइव एंड करने से पहले मैं आपको दो
चीजें बताना चाहता हूं। कुछ चीजें बताना
चाहता हूं। उसको ध्यान रखिएगा। एक तो
एक्सबो के ऊपर वीडियो आएगी बहुत जल्द।
आपको डिटेल वीडियो में बताऊंगा कि
एग्जैक्टली क्या चल रहा है एग्जैक्टली।
आपको समझाऊंगा मैं कि क्या है एक्सबो।
क्यों आपको डरना नहीं चाहिए एंड बेफिक्र
होकर बिंदास होकर काम करना चाहिए। दूसरी
चीज कि डीसीसीआई हमारी साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन की बैच ऑलरेडी जो है वो आने
वाली है। 30 जुलाई से नेक्स्ट बैच स्टार्ट
हो रही है। अभी आपके पास टाइम है ऑफर फी
में एनरोल करने का। आप इस पेज पे आके
dfin.com dcआई पे आके सारी डिटेल्स चेक
आउट कर सकते हैं एंड एनरोल भी कर सकते
हैं। ठीक है? एनरोल कर लीजिएगा। उसके बाद
आपको जो है WhatsApp ग्रुप में ऐड किया
जाएगा 29th ऑफ़ जुलाई तक एंड देन आप आगे
स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं। उसके बाद डीसीएपीटी
बैच जो हमारी वीएपीटी की बैच है वो भी बैच
की अनाउंसमेंट अगस्त में आने वाली है। बट
उसके पहले आप वेटलिस्ट को ज्वाइन करके
हमारे
WhatsApp ग्रुप में ऐड हो सकते हैं। वहां
पे आपको डिटेल्स वगैरह जो है वो सारी आएगी
मिल जाएगी। एंड ये एक हमारा फर्स्ट एंड वन
ऑफ द काइंड ऑफ अ जॉब ओरिएंटेड बैच है।
जहां पे आपको एक्चुअल जॉब ओरिएंटेड
ट्रेनिंग दी जाती है। इंडस्ट्री रिलेवेंट
एंड एक ऐसा बंदा जो 4 साल का एक्सपीरियंस
लेकर बैठा है वीएपीटी में कंपनी में
ऑलरेडी जॉब करता है। वो आपको यहां पे
ट्रेन करेगा। एंड ही विल बी ट्रेनिंग लाइक
इंडस्ट्री में जिस तरीके से ट्रेनिंग होती
है जैसे प्रोजेक्ट पे काम किए जाते हैं
इंडस्ट्री के अंदर वीएपीटी के प्रोजेक्ट्स
पे सिमिलर वे में आपको ट्रेनिंग दी जाएगी।
उसी लेवल की ट्रेनिंग दी जाएगी। एंड हमारे
सात स्टूडेंट्स लर्नर्स ऑलरेडी प्लेस हो
चुके हैं। एंड बहुत से लोगों को बाउंटज
लगी है इस बैच से। तो इट्स अ प्राउड
मोमेंट। तो इसके लिए आपको वेट करना पड़ेगा
एक महीना और बट आप वेट लिस्ट को जो है जॉइ
करके एंड ग्रुप में आ सकते हैं। तब तक के
लिए दैट्स इट। तो ये इंफॉर्मेशन आपको दो
आप लोगों को देनी थी। आई होप कि यू गॉट द
इनफेशन। सो बस फिलहाल के लिए आज के सेशन
में इतना ही। आज के सेशन को हम यहीं पे
एंड कर देंगे। एंड नेक्स्ट लाइव सेशन को
हम बहुत जल्द जो है लेकर आएंगे। नेक्स्ट
लाइव सेशन आपके लिए जहां पे आपके डाउट्स
को और भी डाउट्स जो भी होंगे उसको हम
लेंगे। सो थैंक यू सो मच एवरीबॉडी फॉर
जॉइनिंग दिस सेशन एंड आप सबको मेरी तरफ से
यह नमकीन आप प्लीज इस नमकीन को खाइए और
दिमाग को मस्त कीजिए। आपके तरफ से मैं भी
खा लेता हूं। अगर आप नहीं खा सकते तो आपके
साइड से मैं यह नमकीन खा लेता हूं। एंड
मैं नेक्स्ट वीडियो में मिलते हैं। आल्सो
बग बंटी की क्लासेस आने वाली है। नई
टॉपिक्स आने वाली हैं आप सबके लिए। तो
डेफिनेटली यू वुड बी लविंग दोज़ टॉपिक्स।
सीडीएफ्स एंड वॉक थ्रूज़ हम स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं। चाहे वो टहकमी के हो, HTB के
हो, सब हम स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं। मजे आने
वाले हैं आपको एंड यू वुड बी लविंग दोज़
सीडीएफ्स एंड दोज़ सेशंस क्योंकि वहां आपको
सीखने को बहुत कुछ मिलने वाला है। तो,
आपका बस एक सपोर्ट चाहिए कि जस्ट
जाते-जाते लाइक कर दीजिएगा वीडियो को और
आपके जो वीडियोस हमारे जो आते हैं, जो
लाइव सेशंस आते हैं, उनको शेयर कीजिए अपने
दोस्तों के बीच में। दैट्स इट। नथिंग एल्स
रिक्वायर्ड। थैंक यू सो मच। हैव अ गुड डे
गाइस एंड विश यू ऑल द बेस्ट फॉर योर
करियर। ऑल द बेस्ट। थैंक यू सो मच। बाय।
गुड नाइट।